LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING THE FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
SUPPORTERS. THE SENATE HAS MADE
THE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
OMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS A LAW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL INTO
WISHING PROP PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMON. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. THAT'S EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO SIX NINE SEVEN
NINE ONE FOUR. BATCH. TWO SIX
NINE SEVEN NINE ONE FOUR FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
ALL THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARCH PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY THE
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO. FOUR SUPPORT AN
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT. AND YOU WILL NOW BE.
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING. ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THINK YOU
FOR YOUR- IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE. HEARING ALL THE
BILLS ON SCHEDULE AFTER THE
INITIAL WITNESSES SPENT SUPPORT.
AN OPPOSITION WE WILL BE
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENTS TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE AGAIN
WILL LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENTS TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE I WILL
MAINTAIN THE CHROME DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICES ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. BY EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING AND
IT'S CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME MORE BLACK TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED. PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD- TO LET'S WE HAVE SIX ARE
GOING TO HEARD TODAY BUT LET'S
MAKE AND- THAT. SB THREE ZERO
BISA. CORTESE HAS BEEN POURED
BY THE AUTHOR AND IS NOW A TO
YOUR BILL. AND AGAIN IT WITH
THEIR SIX WERE WANT O. S. FIVE
HOLE FOR BY SENATOR. ON THE WE
HEAR PRESENTE FOR THE BILL LEAD
TO STAB RECORD. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD YOUR BRADFORD A VOGUE
THE TROUBLE CARE LOG. COM HERE
SKI. SKINNER HERE WINNER.
VELCORO A QUORUM IS. BLACK'S
FIRST. THIS WITH THE CONSENT
CAN IS OUR MOST ON CONSENT
CALVET. WE HAVE A MOTION
FOUNTAINS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CALENDAR CAL AS. FIVE
FOUR. BRADFORD AYE IT'S BOTH I
THE TERM GUY COM. CALM WATER
ICE. SKINNER I. IT'S GOING TO
HOLD UP FOR DINNER PERRITT THAT
MEASURE HAS FOR VOTES LEAVE IT-
OPEN FOR ACTION MEMBER. NOW
WILL RAISE FOR OFF I SENATOR
PAN AND ALL HE'S PER S. B.
SEVEN TWO. UPON YOU'RE READY
CENTER PAN THE FLOOR IS YOUR-
THANK YOU CHAIR BRADFORD AND
THEN OF THE SENATE PAUL SAFETY.
FOR- OVER A YEAR OF WORKS BY
SIDE FOLLOW THE SCIENCE DATA
SAVE HIS LIVES. YOU CAN DURING
COVERT NOW OFTEN AT A COST
OTHER PARTS OF THE COMMUTER
LIFE AND FOR HERE IN TELL. WE
KNOW THE THREE PER SEVEN CASE.
OF COVERT NINE AND- OVER SIXTY
DEATHS. WE THE PAIN OF TRYING
GRIEVE FOR THE ONES FROM AFAR
TO STRAIN ON FOR. TO WORK OFTEN
FOR HOME IN SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS LEARNING THROUGH
COMPUTER. THE STRUGGLE SMALL
BUSINESS I. PUSHED THE DOORS-
OPEN EVEN CUSTOMERS CAN COME.
EVEN WORSE OF. KEEP EACH OTHER
SAFE. ALL THESE. WE HAVE GIVE
HAS ABOUT BY TIME TO FIND
MEDICAL BREAKTHROUGHS WHAT
SCIENCE CAN HELP US BRING AN
END TO THESE DARK MOMENTS THAT
CALLED FOR US TO GIVE MORE THAN
WE EVER THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE.
NOW BECAUSE OF DECADES OF
RESEARCH IN SCIENCE AROUND
IMMUNOLOGY WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
BRING THIS PANDEMIC TO A CLOSE.
WE'RE FINALLY STARTING TO
SAFELY REOPEN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT ALL THIS MAY BE LOST IF WE
DON'T GET ENOUGH PEOPLE
VACCINATED. WELL THE FEDERAL
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
DOING BETTER AND BETTER EACH
DAY DISTURBING THE COVER
NINETEEN VACCINES IN EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THE VACCINE. ANTI VACCINE
EXTREMISTS THAT WE ARE ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH HERE ARE
ESCALATING THEIR TACTICS TO
ACTUALLY DISRUPT AND STOP THESE
EFFORTS. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
ASKING YOU TO VOTE FOR SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO. SO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRACTICE FREE SPEECH. YEAH
AND MAKE SURE THE PUBLIC
OFFICIALS HAVE MORE TOOLS TO
ENSURE PATIENTS IN FRONT LINE
WORKERS AT VACCINE CLINICS ARE
SAFE FROM INTIMIDATION
HARASSMENT AND PHYSICAL
DESTRUCTION. MOST OF YOU ARE
AWARE OF THE SHUTDOWN OF THE
VACCINE CLINIC IN JANUARY AT
DODGER STADIUM WHERE A MOB OF
ANTI VACCINE EXTREMISTS
STOPPED. THE CLINIC FROM
OPERATING. WELL THEY SCREAM
MASSLESS AT VULNERABLE PEOPLE
WAITING THEIR CARS TO GET
VACCINATED JEOPARDIZING THE
SAFETY PATIENTS AND FRONTLINE
WORKERS. BUT THESE EXTREMISTS
ARE ALSO PLANNING SIMILAR OP
SIMILAR OPERATIONS ALL OVER THE
STATE OFTEN TRYING TO BLEND IN
THIS FRONT LINE WORKERS AND
DISRUPT OPERATIONS EVEN RESORT
TO TACTICS LIKE TARGETING
FARMWORKERS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST FOR ANY HEAVILY
IMPACT OF NINETEEN. AND NEED A
VACCINE THE MOST. ADDITIONALLY
WHAT WE'RE JUST BACKS INTRODUCE
HEALTHCARE SPACES LIKE
HOSPITALS DOCTORS OFFICES AND
PHARMACIES WE ARE ALSO USING
NONTRADITIONAL LOCATIONS LIKE
STADIUM SCHOOL CAMPUSES PARKING
LOTS. US POP UP CLINICS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS BACK MANY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AT A TIME
OF CREATING NEW LOGISTICS
SITUATIONS THAT MIGHT BE A BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS. THE PHONE
INTO THE BILL WILL FALSELY
CLAIM WERE TAKEAWAYS. THIS IS A
FALSE CHOICE THEY WANT TO BOXES
INTO. WE CAN HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FREE SPEECH WITHOUT
DISRUPTING ACCESS TO VACCINES
FOR PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO GET
THEM. TODAY HAVE TWO WITNESSES
DR TOOL MUKASEY PRIME A PRIMARY
CARE DOCTOR AT THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR OUTPATIENT
CENTER IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
AND FOUNDER OF A GROUP OF THE
THOUSANDS OF THOUSANDS OF
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AROUND
THE COUNTRY THEY'RE EDUCATING
PEOPLE ABOUT THE SAFETY
IMPORTANCE OF THE COVER
NINETEEN VACCINE CALLED THIS IS
OUR SHOT. I KNOW DR- NOT. NOT
BECAUSE IS STEPPING AWAY FROM
PATIENTS BE ABLE TO BE WITH US
TODAY TO TESTIFY SO WE'LL HEAR
FROM HIM FIRST AND- THEN WE'LL
HEAR FROM CATHERINE MARTIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUSICIAN COALITION
DOES WORKING WITH PARTNERS ALL
OVER THE STATE. TO DISTRIBUTE
THE VACCINE PARTICULARLY TO OUR
MOST NEEDY COMMUNITIES. I AGAIN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES AND UP. THE HAVE A
WITNESSES STOP PRESENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL PROVIDE OUR
FIVE MINUTES EACH SIDE FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO DOCTOR
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
BAM BAM YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
AYE YOU ABLE TO ME OKAY. YOU.
OKAY WONDERFUL- I APPRECIATE
THE PLAYERS HERE I MY NAME'S TO
COME ON OFTEN HERE OFF AND THE
BILL HAS IMPORTANT TO ME IN
FACT- I'M GETTING TIME IN
BETWEEN PATIENTS RIGHT NOW AND
MARK KING TALPADE CENTER-
INTERNET UNDER BRADFORD KNOW
YOU'RE TO BE NO THE HERE- AND
THEN PATIENT THIS MORNING- MANY
YOU KNOW THAT ARE PAID ARE VERY.
EIGHTY PER OF MY AND WALK MAKE
UNDER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND A YEAR
AND THEY LIVE ON THAT AND IT
MIGHT BE ON LEVEL TO LIVE IN
THE TWENTY COUNTRY MY PATIENTS
ARE US. NOW WE HAVE THIS
MIRACLE OF SCIENCE. MANY
PATIENTS THAT YOU MAY NOT
OPERATE LIKE FROM THAT BUT FOR
MY PATIENTS THE DOG SUFFERING
LIFE FROM DEATH FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE ARE STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE. AND WE HAVE NOT MADE
IT EASY FOR THE BUDGET THEY
HAVE HAD MANY OBSTACLES AND
HARDSHIPS WHETHER ACCESSING THE
BACKSEAT WHETHER IT'S THE
ABILITY TO TRANSPORT THEMSELVES
WHETHER TO NAVIGATE THE HEALTH
SYSTEM THE INTERNET TO FIND UPS
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE STORY AND
NEEDS AND THE PERSONAL OUR
NARRATIVES OF OUR PATIENTS WHO
STRUGGLE ACT OF THE BACKBEAT.
SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT PUTTING
THE ENOUGH IS ENOUGH THAT WE
WILL NOT OBSTRUCTION
INTIMIDATION HOSTILITY AND
HARASSMENT OF THE DIVISIONAL
BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS WHO NEED
THE VACCINE AND THAT BILL IS
NOT ONLY ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
SPEECH BUT IT'S ABOUT THE RIGHT
TO LIFE. TO A LIFESAVING
BACKSEAT. FINALLY I DON'T
THEMSELVES. ON ON AND ON FROM
THEY ARE A DOUBLE THREAT TO MY
FACE NOT ONLY A OF A BUT AS OF
THE- THIS BILL WOULD HELP. THAT
DOT TRACK AND PROTECT THE BAKER
NATURE OF THE LIFE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE BY GIVING THEM A
STATE BACK TO BACK THE NEW.
WITH JUMPSTART AND INTIMIDATE.
FINALLY I THINK WE ALL
GRATITUDE TO THE MANY STAFF AND
ALL WERE STAFF THE BY THE
PUBLIC SERVICE WE HAVE RETIRED
NURSES RETIRED DOCTORS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS EVEN OUR OWN
MEDICAL STUDENTS WHO ARE
VOLUNTEERING THEIR WEEKENDS AND
EVENINGS STOP ACTING NATION BY
FOR SUCH PUBLIC SERVICE I ASK
SHOULD WE NOT ALL BIRDS SUCH
PUBLIC SAFETY. PUBLIC SERVICE
SHOULD WE NOT OFFERED SUCH
PUBLIC SAFETY FROM WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN. IN RECENT TIMES IN RECENT
MOMENT. FINALLY I ASKED THE
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY ONE OF THE
PRICE OF A HUMAN LIFE. I CAN
TELL YOU BECAUSE I'VE SIGNED
THE DEATH CERTIFICATE BUT MY
PATIENCE THE PAST YEAR. THANK
YOU. I WISH THEY WOULD HAVE
LIVED TO BE A MOMENT SENATOR
BRADFORD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THE VACCINE WOULD SAVE THEIR
LIFE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
REALLY IS ABOUT AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FOUR TWO. ABOUT THAT ONE STEP
CLOSER TO STATING THEIR SACRED
LIFE AND WE WISH THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN HERE WITH US
TODAY IN THIS MOMENT TO RECEIVE
THE FLY TIPPING BACK THING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
CALPERS FLORES MY AND I'M YEAR
THANK YOU DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION OF STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT WITH THE MISSION OF
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO LIFE SAVING VACCINES.
BLOOD WORK IN THE FIELD OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND IMMUNIZATION
FOR NEARLY TWENTY THREE YEARS
WITH THE TRAJECTORY OF ACTING
REFUSAL. WE'VE BEEN A SMALL NOT
OF INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES WHO
DECLINED TO VACCINATE
THEMSELVES FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
FOR PERSONAL OR MEDICAL REASONS
BUT THIS NUMBER HAS GROWN AND
EVOLVED PARTICULARLY OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS AND DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IT'S BECOME A
MOVEMENT THAT INVOLVES
MISINFORMATION PROTEST THREATS
INTIMIDATION AND SOMETIMES
VIOLENCE. BUT OVER THE PAST
FOUR MONTHS OR PUBLIC HEALTH
HEROES HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AN
ENORMOUS BY BACK MEETING EARLY
TWENTY SIX MILLION ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE FOX FOUR
MONTHS FROM GETTING THE BACKING
TO THAT MANY PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING THEIR TURN VOLUNTARILY
WAITING IN LONG LINES PUTTING
THEIR TRUST ME FINE AND DOING
THEIR. PART TO GET US OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC. WE STILL HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO WE KNOW THAT
SOME PEOPLE ARE STILL IN A WEEK
C. MOBILE ONE HAVE WORKED
MENTIONED THEY HAVE A LONG LIST
OF QUESTIONS PERHAPS THE NEED
THAT TIME. WITH THE INFORMATION
TO REACH THEIR DECISION AND
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THEM WE
VALUE INFORMATION AND MAKING
SURE PEOPLE HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO MAKE THAT SHORT. I KNOW
NOTHING NOT SO GOOD PARTS. THE
NETWORK IS WORK SPREAD
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE
DISEASE ABOUT MASKING BAXEEN.
ACTIVITIES RANGE FROM SETTING
UP CABLES WITH ANTI VACCINE
LITERATURE PROTEST. MASBACK
NATION CLINICS. ONE VERTICAL
RECRUITING OTHER SPANISH
SPEAKERS IN THEIR NETWORK TO GO
OUT TO THE FIELD TO QUOTE
EDUCATE AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
AGAINST. THE BACK NATION. OTHER
GROUPS OF SPECIFICALLY TARGETED
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
TO HIGHLIGHT PASSED. NECK WOULD
BE SPREAD OUT. NOT GOING TO GO.
SOME OF THE CAL TO ROUTINELY
PROTEST BACKED CHAIR OF THE-
WE'RE ALL IN LAS DC ON JAN SIX.
HOLDING OF FREEDOM FREE RALLY
AND FROM OF THEM YOU WANT TO
CAPITAL THAT. W. THE SCREENING
THE THREAT HIM FROM GROUPS THE
CAP IT'S ROUGH FOR US TO WATCH
RIGHT. FOR PROFESSIONAL TO THEM
IN THE IT SEEMS IN A CAR OR
JEAN A CLINIC. IT'S AN COME OR
EVEN FRIGHTENING. FRESHMAN
COMMITTEE THE AND WORK HEALTH.
HELP ALL BECAUSE DIRECTOR WHO
HAD PROTEST OUT THEIR HOME.
OVER THE PAST YEAR COULD NOT
GET NUMBER CALLED DR DIRECTORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY A CLUSTER
CHANGE POSITION. I KNOW YOU
CAN. BE THE MOST. THANK YOU
REPUBLICAN PUBLIC PROFESSIONALS
BUT MUST DEPARTMENT PORTENTS
WHEREVER GOING TO GET THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE STRONG. WORD WE
CLOSE THAN A LOT OF. COMPANIES
THAT SEEM TO STATE AND
EFFECTIVE MANY NOT STATES BUT
MOST TENDER MILLIONS OF THREE
MILLION. ARE NEEDED EVERY DAY.
OUR CHILDREN ARE BEEN THROUGH
ENOUGH WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR
THE MOMENT THEN WORKING TOWARDS
GETTING BACK TO OUR LIVES SO WE
MUST ENSURE THE STATE OF THE
PUBLIC AND PROFESSIONAL TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL. YEAH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AROUND SHE DID HERE TO THE-
MINUTES PER SE. WE KNOW THAT
RENDON LITTLE NOTHING- AND- WE
WILL TO- ANY. WOULDN'T HE- AND-
THE CHAMBER. IS SHE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FOUR TWO.
SHEEN NINE IT WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM OF. THAT TWENTY
FORTY I SEE NO ONE THERE NOW
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR SEVEN TWO
WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY JUST TO
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. PINE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PRICE DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT IF YOU'RE. LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING KELLY BEING
REPRESENTING HEALTH NET AND
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND WELLNESS
IN UPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR TWO
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DAVID KRIEGER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS A HOLLOW REGARDING THE
BILL CONTRACTORS WE STRONGLY AT
THE COMMITTEE TO PROTECT EACH
OTHER RIGHT ACTED BACKING BABY
BY VOTING I. LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS JOHN
LOCAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS.
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY. POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIANS AS OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FALLING
SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY IS ABOUT
SAVING LIVES. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
MODERATOR I WOULD HAVE SAID SHE
CHECKED THE ALARM ONE MORE TIME
FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AGAIN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTION ANY WITNESSES
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ON OPPOSITION AGAIN
WERE UP FORTY FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL. WE HAVE JOSHUA COLEMAN
AND WE HAVE MATH THROUGH-
MCREYNOLDS SO. MODERATOR ARE
THEY QUEUED UP OR IN PERSON
EITHER OF YOUR HERE IN PERSON
OKAY. JOSHUA COLEMAN HERE'S AN
PER PERSON SO THANK YOU. THE
SUPPORT WOULD FOR SIX MINUTES
AND FORTY SEVEN SECONDS CAN I
PLEASE HAVE A THREE MINUTES
TWENTY SECONDS I'LL GIVE YOU
THREE MINUTES TWENTY SECONDS.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS JOSHUA
COLEMAN I LIVE IN ROSEVILLE AND
CO FOUNDER OF V. IS FOR
VACCINE. THE LARGEST VACCINE
RISK PUBLIC AWARENESS EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION. OUR CAMPAIGN IS
BEING USED AROUND THE WORLD AND
IN ALL FIFTY STATES. I SHOULD
MENTION I DON'T FEEL SENSUAL
OILS FOLLOW Q. AND ON AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THE WORLD IS FLAT.
I HAVE TWO SONS BOTH HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED. MY OLDEST SON AUTO
EXPERIENCED AN ADVERSE TO. ADD
ADVERSE REACTION TO VACCINES.
CALLED TRANSVERSE MYELITIS HE
IS NOW PARALYZED FROM THE WAIST
DOWN. AND CONFINED TO A
WHEELCHAIR FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE. I WAS NEVER INFORMED AN
INJURY LIKE THIS WAS EVEN
REMOTELY POSSIBLE REGARDLESS OF
THE TRANSVERSE MYELITIS WAS
LISTED IN THE ANSWER TO THE
VACCINES HE WAS GIVEN. AND IS
ALSO ON THE GOVERNMENT'S
VACCINE INJURY COMPENSATION
PROGRAM LIST OF COMPENSABLE
INJURIES. I DIDN'T RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE INFORMED CONSENT.
BEFORE ALLOWED AUTO TO BE
VACCINATED AND SINCE THEN I'VE
BEEN ON A MISSION TO BETTER
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC. ABOUT THE
REAL RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
VACCINATION. THE VACCINE
PROGRAM LIKE ALL THINGS IN THIS
WORLD ISN'T PERFECT. AND THERE
IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD OFFERING
LITTLE KNOWN YET FACTUAL
INFORMATION ON VACCINES NEAR
WHERE VACCINATIONS ARE GIVEN IS
ONE OF THE WAYS. WE RAISE
AWARENESS ON THE SUBJECT. THERE
ARE OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
PHARMACIES IN CALIFORNIA.
ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED HOSPITALS
AND WHEN YOU INCLUDE PRIVATE
PRACTICES CLINICS COVERED
NINETEEN VACCINATION SITES. WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT OVER TEN
THOUSAND LOCATIONS IN THIS IN
THIS STATE WHERE IF THIS BILL
IS PASSED. CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
SEVERELY LIMITED IN THEIR RIGHT
TO PEACEFULLY ASSEMBLE AND
EXERCISE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
THIS IS A VERY EXTREME
LEGISLATION AND COMPLETELY
VIOLATES THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO
THE CONSTITUTION. CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF WOMEN WERE TOLD THAT
THEY WERE LIMITED WHERE THEY
COULD PROTEST FOR THEIR RIGHT
TO VOTE OR AFRICAN AMERICANS
WERE LIMITED TO WHERE THEY
COULD PROTEST AGAINST
SEGREGATION. WHERE WOULD WE BE
NOW. THE DODGER STADIUM
INCIDENT THAT TOOK PLACE ON
JANUARY THIRTIETH THAT WAS
TALKED ABOUT WAS INCORRECTLY
REPORTED ON SAYING ACTIVISTS
HAD BLOCKED PEOPLE FROM BEING
VACCINATED. THERE WERE POLICE
ON SITE AND L. A. COUNTY CHIEF
OF POLICE MICHAEL MOORE MADE A
PUBLIC STATEMENT SAYING THE
POLICE DID NOT SHUT DOWN THE
VACCINATION SITE. ALL
APPOINTMENTS ARE BEING MET. CNN
REPORTED THE GATHERING WAS
PEACEFUL AND NO ARRESTS WERE
MADE ALSO STATING NO
APPOINTMENTS WERE CANCELLED.
HALF THE CITIZENS IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST
ONE COVERED NINETEEN SHOT AND
THERE HASN'T BEEN ONE INCIDENT
WHERE ACTIVISTS DISRUPTED A
COVERT NINETEEN VACCINATION
AREA PREVENTING VACCINATIONS
FROM HAPPENING. AS OF NOW IF
PROTESTERS GO OUT AND ACTUALLY
BLOCK A VACCINATION AREA. THEY
CAN BE ARRESTED WE ALREADY HAVE
LAWS IN PLACE WHERE IT'S
ILLEGAL TO DO THAT. IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT THE COMPELLING
STATE INTEREST IS FOR THIS BILL
IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT NEEDED TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM DOING
SOMETHING THAT IS ALREADY
AGAINST THE LAW. PLEASE VOTE
DOWN SB SEVEN FOUR TWO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WILL
MOVE TO THE MATH FOR YOU
MACKERELS WHO'S ON THE PHONE
LINE. HELLO GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU CHAIR. SO THE COMMITTEE.
HERE'S SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH THE PACIFIC JUSTICE
INSTITUTE CENTER FOR PUBLIC
POLICY AND IT WILL NOT POSITION
TO THE BILL- BEFORE AND
CERTAINLY DIFFERENT RENEWAL
ALSO COMES WITH THE BILL HER
COURTS. TO DO AND THE RHETORIC-
DIFFERENT SUPPORT ARE VERY VERY
GOOD CURRENT CRIME ONE THE BILL.
YEAH SECTION BURKE AND WE WOULD
URGE TO TAKE RAM CLOSE LOOK AT
THE KIDS CAN EXPECT. THE
OPERATIVE SECTION SECTION ONE
EIGHT. FIRST DEFINITIONAL
PROTECTING. THE FOR FUNDING
ISSUE OF TO. OPERATIVES WHAT
CRIMINAL. AT SOME OF THE LARGE
EVENTS. I BETTER THAN MENTIONED
STADIUMS. HOW IN KNOW. WITH THE
PROTESTS OF NO CONNECTION TO
THE VACCINES THEMSELVES YEAH
DEFINITELY DEFINITIONAL
SECTION. THE CLEAN UP. WE WERE
IRAQ. THAT'S RESULT OPERATIVE
SEX WOULD CRIMINALIZE ALL
MANNER OF PROTEST. AT THE
VACCINE COULD WITH THAT COST.
WHETHER THAT BE RETAIL INSTEAD.
BUT AT LEAST ONE WE CURRENTLY
OF WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LABOR PICKETING BLACK LIVES
MATTER PROTESTS OR EVEN THE
RIGHT TO LIFE PICKETING OUTSIDE
OF ABORTION CLINICS DID WE
DOUBT THAT THE AUTHOR INTENDED
THOSE CONSEQUENCES BUT THEY ARE
THE NATURAL CONSEQUENCES OF THE
CURRENT PROPERTY TAX AND
THEREFORE WE WOULD STRONGLY
URGE AMENDMENTS. TO REMOVE THE
MENTION OF PICKETING- AS WELL
AS TO FOCUS THE BILL ONE- AWAY
FROM. TARGETING COOPERATIVE
TECH. STATE ANY CURRENT FORM
THE BILL GOES SETTLEMENT. THAN
WHAT IT'S BEEN PRESENTED AT
THAT WE BELIEVE RECALL. ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL EXITED ALONG THE
RISE CURRENTLY PREVENT CRAB OF
THE EXTRACTS. THAT HAS BEEN
SIGNED. YOU KNOW THERE'S NO FOR
BILL GOES SO FOR. IN WOODLANDS
WELL BEYOND THE- NINE. CRISIS
YOU DOESN'T WANT ITSELF EVEN
THOSE KIND OF SHOTS ANY
ESTABLISHMENT THAT GIVES OUT
COLUSA. INSULATOR OUT FROM
PROTEST UNDER THIS. SO FOR THE
REASONS WE WENT IN TO REJECT
THE BILL IN ITS FORM THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOW WILL TO WHERE
HERE IN AND FORTY TWO OLD YOU
CAN STATE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION. THAT THE EXTENT OF
YOUR TESTIMONY AND THEN. WILL
MOVE TO FOR MARCH. WELL I. MY
NAME IS MIKE. WHAT THE FUNKY
FATHERS REPRESENTING. TEN
MILLION MAN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
AND THIS BILL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AT ITS CORE.
ANY TIME YOU TRY TO AMEND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT YOU'RE
VIOLATING YOUR OATH OF OFFICE
TO PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION
CONSTITUTION. IS YOUR OR A- WE
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR SPEECH
WE'RE ASKING FOR IT WE'RE
ASKING FOR YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION I'M I'M A HUMAN BEING
WE KNOW WHAT YOU ARE W ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME IN YOUR POSITION
AUTHOR OF THE BILL ADAM STATING
MY POSITION MY POSITION EITHER
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. HE EVEN PUT THIS
FORWARD IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VIOLATED YOUR CALL TAKE YOU
WITH IS YOUR- PEOPLE. THIS IS
YOUR BILL TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
RIGHT WE ARE PEOPLE THE CHAIN
THE CARPET THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE AND OPPOSITION
TO S. B. SEVEN FOUR TWO. ALL
RIGHT THEN LET'S MOVE TO THE
OVERFLOW A WE HAVE ONE MORE
AGAIN YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. MY NAME. IS
THE ANDREA HAD STRUM. MY
AFFILIATION. IS A VACCINE
INJURED. MOTHER OF. FOUR
SOVEREIGN HUMAN BEING. FIRST
AMENDMENT LOVING. CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE NEVER
FOLLOWING AWAY. THANK YOU NOW
LET'S MOVE TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
IN TWENTY FORTY IS ARE THERE%
WITNESSES C. NINE THEIR
MODERATOR LET'S GO THROUGH THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES WERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
TRUST ONE THAT THAN THEIR- AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE NOT
THEN THEY'RE ALL. BLIND TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS CHRISTINA HELD RAN FOR LIKE
TO TRADE ADVOCACY- WE EDUCATE
AND ADVOCATE FOR IMPLEMENTATION
AT TRANSPARENCY OF WHAT GOES
INTO YOUR BODY THIS BILL IS
NEED A NARROWLY TAILORED OR
NEUTRAL- WHICH ARE TWO OF THE
PIECES THAT NEED TO BE. IN
PLACE FOR IT TO BE
CONSTITUTIONAL SAY WE OPPOSE IT
FOR THE REASONS PAGE WITNESSED
IT KATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THIS. NINE SIX THREE LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS STACY.
AND AM ADAMANT OPPOSITION SB
SEVEN FOUR Q. AS IN VACCINE
INJURED CITIZEN OF SACRAMENTO
AND A FIRST AMENDMENT LEVINE
AMERICAN THIS IS A VIOLATION
ACROSS THE BOARD FORGET STOP-
SHUT DOWN OPPOSED THAT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MARY LEASH
WRITER AND DIRECTOR RIGHT TO
LIFE OF KERN COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN FORTY
TWO. NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TYLER
BAGLEY IN ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA
I JUST WANTED TO NOTE MY
EXTREME OPPOSITION IS COMING
FORTY TWO. NINE SIXTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY NAME IS
KELLY FACT I'M CALLING FROM
SUCH AS HEIGHTS AND I OPPOSE-
THIS DISCRIMINATORY AND FULL OF
CENSORSHIP THE BILL. NINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME STEP FLAYED I'M IN
PORTRAIT TYPE CALIFORNIA I'M A
PARENT OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL IT WILL LIMIT OUR ACCESS
TO BE ABLE TO GET APPROVAL
INFORMATION NOT MISINFORMATION
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY MANY
PEOPLE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
AND IN CALIFORNIA DO NOT KNOW
THAT VACCINE MANUFACTURERS DO
NOT HAVE LIABILITY FOR THEIR
PRODUCT THEY ALSO DON'T KNOW.
MUCH MORE INFORMATION AND THAT
IS WHAT BE PROVIDED AND
SILENTLY OUR MOVEMENT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWENTY
ONE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED
CONSTITUTION PREVENTS THE
GOVERNMENT FROM MAKING LAWS
WHICH REGULATE AN ESTABLISHMENT
OF RELIGION OR THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE FREE EXERCISE OF
RELIGION OR BRIDGE THE FREEDOM
OF SPEECH THE FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS FREEDOM OF ASSEMBLY BUT
THE RIGHT TO PETITION THE
GOVERNMENT FOR A REDRESS OF
GRIEVANCES SB CENTREBOARD TO
CURTAILED. FOUR OUT OF FIVE OF
THOSE RIGHTS IT IS AN EIGHTY
ONE GUYS AYE OPPOSED SEVEN
COURT YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS BUT. BLIND TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOT MY JOY
AND I'LL AFFILIATE WOULD BE
L'ANNONCE OF ALL. WHEN I'M BOTH
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S NAME. I'D
LIKE TO INVOKE ANOTHER NAME
DOCTOR. VALUE MORE WHO NOT ONLY
WAS IGNORED AND DISRESPECTED
THE ULTIMATELY KILLED BY THE
BROKEN MEDICAL SYSTEM. SHE WAS
A MEDICAL DOCTOR. IN THE BLACK
FROM HAVE A- FOR IN YEARS AND
PART OF ONE OF THE ALLEN DOES
IT SPEAK TO THAT WHEN WE GO OUT
AND PROTEST. AND NOW YOU WANT
TO COME OUT OF AGAIN. PROBABLY
CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR EVEN. OUT
AGAINST THE DISPARITIES IT'S
JUST IT'S A TRAP AND IT THE
RACKET. AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
STAND FOR IT ARE YOU STANDING
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS YEAH THANK YOU.
BY FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS WHEN IT STILL I
SERVICE THE DIRECT OF CAL FOR
LIFE. AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
DISCRIMINATORY BILL THANK YOU.
FIND FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS I THINK IN
COLLEGE I AM A CONSTITUENT OF
OTHER HAND I HAVE THE BACKING
INJURED FAMILY MEMBER IN NEED
INJURIES ARE VERY REAL ACTING
RISK AWARENESS IS IMPORTANT ANY
DEMONSTRATIONS OFFER KNOWLEDGE
TO PEOPLE THAT THEY HAVE A
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TRYING TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM SHOOTING THE BACK
LATE WE ARE SIMPLY GIVING THEM
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO.
HAVE WE OPPOSE. FIND LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS KATHERINE
MCBRIDE AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB SEVEN FOUR TWO-
INFORMED CONSENT IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AND- IT IS
AND- OF FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT
TO BE ABLE TO- TICKET AT A
VACCINATION SITE. PLEASE VOTE
NO ON SB SEVEN FOUR TWO THANK
YOU. BY TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TANYA AND
I'M CALLING FROM ROCKLAND
CALIFORNIA I'M PRO CHOICE BUT I
WORK IN WITH WHOLE LIFE
ACTIVIST WHO WHOSE MISSION IS
TO MAKE THOSE SEEKING ABORTION
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF SUPPORT
OR FINANCIAL SUPPORT AWARE OF
THE ALTERNATIVE AND HELP THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO THEM WE DO THIS
IN MANY CASES OUT OUTSIDE THE
ABORTION CLINIC THAT WOULD FALL
UNDER THE CATEGORY OF BACK
NATION FIGHT. BILL WOULD
RESTRICT THE GOOD WORK WE ARE
DOING TO HELP MOTHERS WHO FEEL
THEY HAVE NO OTHER OPTION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. WHY TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ANDREAS
ON TONY FROM SAN FRANCISCO IN
THIS SHOW BILL AS WORDED IS
OVERLY BROAD RESTRICTIONS ON
FREE SPEECH MUST BE EXTREMELY
NARROW MUST NOT TARGET A
PARTICULAR VIEWPOINT INVEST
I'VE CHECKED WITH THIS BILL.
THE QUICKNESS AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THAT
SHE CHECKED ONE MORE TIME FOR
WITH THIS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MODERATE. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO. TO BE
JUST A MOMENT WE HAVE A FEW
MORE KILLING ALL.
NINE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS SHANNON HEIL I'M CALLING
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FOUR TWO THIS
IS A COMPLETE IN OTHER BREACH
ON OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH OR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT EVERYBODY
HAS THE RIGHT YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY ARE DOING MY BODY MY
CHOICE. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
HEATHER KELLER AND I'M CALLING
IN TO STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. SEVEN
FOUR TWO. THE MIND SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO
THIS IS TO READ THE READ IN
FROM THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE
AS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU- WE'RE
GOING TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CENTER WIENER. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
WHICH I SUPPORT- AND OFFERS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN THE
FACE OF PERSONAL ATTACKS AND
PHYSICAL ASSAULTS AND- ALL
SORTS OF OTHER HARASSMENT ON TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE CAN PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
WHETHER IT'S FOR MEASLES OR
WHETHER IT'S FROM COVE IN
NINETEEN- AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
ABOUT THE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC I THINK WE
CHOSE TO THREE MILLION PEOPLE
WORLDWIDE. WHO HAVE DIED FOR
GOOD FROM CO THERE WERE A I
THINK WHAT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
OR THEREABOUTS. IN THE UNITED
STATES ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND OR
SO PEOPLE HAVE DIED- IN
CALIFORNIA- AND IN THE MIDST OF
IT WE HAVE. WHO ARE- DID. DENY
THAT THIS VIRUS EVEN EXISTS OR
THINK IT'S JUST LIKE THE COMMON
COLD. AND YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK
AT. THE WAY THAT THIS COUNTRY
IN THIS WORLD HAVE BEEN TORN
APART. BY THIS PANDEMIC NOTCHES
ECONOMICALLY- BUT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHOSE FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
TORN APART PEOPLE DIED. PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THIS VIRUS AND I'M NOT
RECOVERED A YEAR LATER AND MAY
HAVE PERMANENT- INJURIES AS A
RESULT. OF THIS VIRUS- IT IS.
PARTS OF THE GLOBAL HEALTH
DISASTER THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
IN A VERY. VERY VERY LONG TIME-
AND WE KNOW THAT VACCINATION IS
HOW WE GET OUT OF THIS. AND
THEN IT- SEND YOUR PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWED TO HAVE WHATEVER
OPINION THEY WANT TO HAVE. ONE
ON THE VACCINE EVERYONE'S
ENTITLED TO THEIR OWN OPINION.
AND WE NO ONE'S BEING FORCED.
TO GET VACCINATED- BUT WHEN YOU
START INTERFERING WITH THE
ABILITY OF OTHER PEOPLE. TO GET
VACCINATED DOTS WHEN YOU CROSS
THE LINE. YOUR CALL ASSEMBLY
YOU CROSS THE LINE POINTING TO
MAKE STATEMENTS I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD GET VACCINATED
PEOPLE CAN PEOPLE YEAH I
DISAGREE I DISAGREE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE CAN MAKE THAT STATEMENT.
BUT WHEN YOU START PHYSICALLY
IMPEDING THE ABILITY OF OTHER
PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED- YOU
ARE CROSSING A LINE AND THAT IS
NOT FIRST AMENDMENT. ACTIVITY
UNFORTUNATELY WE SEE THIS
CONTINUING CASCADE OF PEOPLE
HAVING THEIR OWN DEEPLY HELD
VIEWS BUT THEN TRYING TO.
HAVING OUR OWN DEEPLY HELD
VIEWS ABOUT WHETHER OTHER
PEOPLE SHOULD SEEK HEALTH CARE
WHETHER IT'S REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE VACCINATIONS AND
INSTEAD OF SIMPLY HAVING OR
SPELLS IN THAT VIEW. AND SAID
THE INSIDE OF THE SENATE THEY
DON'T WANT OTHER PEOPLE TO GET
THAT HEALTHCARE. THEY ARE. TRY
TO PREVENT AND HARASS AND
INTIMIDATE THOSE PEOPLE FROM
GETTING HEALTHCARE WHETHER IT'S
WOMEN WHO ARE SEEKING
REPRODUCTIVE. HEALTH WHETHER
IT'S SOMEONE GETTING A VACCINE
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SOMEONE'S DECISION TO GET
HEALTH CARE THAT IS A VERY
PERSONAL DECISION. M. IT'S A
VERY VERY PERSONAL DECISION AND
THE IDEA. FOR ANY OF US ANY
KIND OF HEALTH CARE GOING TO
YOUR DOCTOR TO A CLINIC OR
ANYWHERE AND YOU OTHER PEOPLE
GETTING UP IN YOUR FACE TRYING
TO PREVENT YOU FROM GETTING OUT
HEALTHCARE I'M SORRY THAT IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE IT IS
DESTRUCTIVE IT IS NOT FIRST
AMENDMENT ACTIVITY- AND IT AND
IT'S ISN'T IT IS NOT OKAY- AND
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO GET HEALTH
CARE. YOU CAN YOU CAN DECIDE
NOT TO GET THAT THE CODE
BAXEEN- BUT BUT STOP
OBSTRUCTING OTHER PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO DO SO AND SO I MOVED
BILL. DO ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE. CAN SEE NONE DUCK
OUT OF THIS A SENATOR OR CHOI
BOOK. GOOD AFTERNOON. OR GOOD
MORNING ACTIONS HE FEELS LONGER
THAN HE SHOULD APOLOGIZE- SO I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- AND
COMMENTS AS WELL BECAUSE I MAY
DAY I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO- OF
COURSE OUR FIRST AMENDMENT DOES
YOU KNOW HAVING OUR OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPRESS OURSELVES AND- AND
UNDERSTANDING THE- IMPORTANCE
OF IT. WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
DEMOCRACY. FIRST OF ALL LET ME
ASK. FOR SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF
WHO DOESN'T HAVE SPECIAL
AWARENESS- VERY MUCH- WHAT IS
THE- THREE HUNDRED FEET LOOK
LIKE IN THIS IN THIS BUILDING
FOR INSTANCE IS IT FROM HERE TO
THAT DOOR- WHAT EXACTLY THIS
THREE HUNDRED DOES ANYBODY KNOW
WHAT THREE HUNDRED FEET LOOK
LIKE. ALL THE- AT THE FOOTBALL
FIELD YEAH BERMAN AND TO THE
OTHER END YOU ARE. OKAY SO IT
WOULD BE I'M ASSUMING IT'S
DEEPER THAN THIS BUILDING. IS
THAT CORRECT BUT CERTAIN DOUBLE
SLEEPER THAN THIS ROOM BUT- YES
OKAY BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT YOU
CAN SHOUT FROM THE BACK OF THE
ROOM. AT THE FRONT AS WE
WITNESS STAND PAST HEARINGS.
OKAY AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD WAS- WITH
REGARDS TO I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT IN DODGER STADIUM FOR THE
PHYSICALLY OBSTRUCTED THE
ENTRANCE BUT THERE WERE OVER
THREE HUNDRED FEET PERHAPS AWAY
FROM SOMETHING VACCINATION THE
ACTUAL PLACE WHAT TOOK PLACE.
OKAY I HAVE- OKAY SO THE- THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAD WAS WITH
REGARDS TO- THE PRIVACY OF
HEALTH- AND HOW DOES THAT
COMBINED WITH- THE ABILITY TO
GET THE VACCINES THAT HAVE THAT
PRIVACY HAVE A- NOTION IN
PLACE- AND THE REASON I ASK IS
BECAUSE- THE I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXPRESS AND HAVE
THAT FREEDOM TO ASSEMBLE. HOW
DOES THAT WORK WITH REGARDS TO
THE PRIVACY OF THE HAVE.
PATIENTS COMING IN AND GETTING
VACCINATED. WELL SO THE
CHALLENGE WOULD BE IS THAT YOU
HAVE- THE PEOPLE WISH TO
DISRUPT- THEY WILL USE A
VARIETY OF TACTICS TO TRY TO
BULLY AND INTIMIDATE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CHOSEN TO GET THE VACCINE-
THEY COULD TRY TO ACTUALLY TAKE
PICTURES OF THEM AND POSTED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA SO THERE BY
VIOLATING THE PRIVACY- THEY
YEAH CERTAINLY- SAID WE
ACTUALLY WITNESSED I'M GOING
RIGHT UP TO PEOPLE'S. A CAR
SELL IT OVER DOCTOR STADIUM.
SHOUTING AT THEM AND BASS BUT
CERTAINLY IN VISUAL RANGE AND-
DOWNSTAIRS PHOTOS WERE TAKEN AS
WELL SO I THINK THERE IS A
PRIVACY RISK AS WELL DEPENDING
ON THE BEHAVIOR OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO DISRUPT AND-
I THINK- WE'VE SEEN TO ANTI
VACCINE EXTREMISTS USER ID
DIFFERENT TACTICS TO TRY TO.
BULLY AND INTIMIDATE AND-
PEOPLE FROM ACTUALLY PURSUING
THEIR OWN HEALTHCARE CHOICES.
SO I'M I'M I'M VERY CAUTIOUS
BECAUSE I AM VERY- I HAVE MET
WITH MANY PARENTS WHO ARE- WHO
HAVE UNFORTUNATELY- HAD
CHILDREN WHO HAD HAD ADVERSE
REACTIONS TO VACCINES- YOU KNOW
I AM A PARENT WHO CHOSE TO HAVE
MY PARENT MY HILDREN
VACCINATED- SO I'M VERY I'M
VERY. SENSITIVE AND VERY
EMPATHETIC TO BOTH BOTH SIDES
AS TO HAVING THE OPTION OF
BEING VACCINATING TO PARENTS
WHO CHOOSE NOT TO BECAUSE OF
THE- THE HISTORY AREN'T THERE-
GENETIC PRE. DISPOSITIONS TO
ADVERSE REACTIONS TO VACCINES
SO. I THINK THERE HAS TO BE A
BALANCE- WITH THIS BILL I FEEL
THAT BOTH ON THE PROTECTION OF
THE OF THE PATIENTS COMING IN-
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
PROTECTED THEIR PRIVACY IS
PROTECTED AND SO FORTH. I
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THIS BILL
AND IN TRYING TO GET THAT
PRIVACY ELEMENT COMPONENT ON
THAT END- BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT. THIS BILL
DOESN'T NECESSARILY. PROHIBIT
SOMEONE FROM EXPRESSING OR OR
SHARING THEIR PERSPECTIVE OR
THEIR VIEWS IT'S JUST IT'S
CREATING A BUFFER SOUND TO
CREATE THAT PRIVACY- THAT'S THE
WAY THAT I'M READING THE BILL
AS SOMEONE WHO IS VERY VERY
PROTECTIVE OF OUR OF OUR OUR
OUR ABILITY TO EXPRESS YOURSELF
IN IT AND ASSEMBLE PROTECTING
THAT FIRST AMENDMENT BUT I ALSO
SEE THAT AS- WE HAVE TO FIND A
LITTLE BIT OF A BALANCE- FOR
PEOPLE ONE TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ASSEMBLE A NUMBER TO HAVE
THAT PRIVACY FOR THE PATIENTS.
AND I SEE THAT IF THREE HUNDRED
FEET SEEMS A LITTLE DAUNTING
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW- FROM THE
OPPOSITION AS TO WHAT WOULD BE
A REASONABLE- BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE TO HAVE THAT BALANCE AND I
WANT I WANT BOTH SIDES TO PUT
THEMSELVES IN THE OPPOSITE-
PERSPECTIVE IN AN- AND-
POSITIONS. WHEN YOU'RE- A
PATIENT. AIRDATE YOU ARE
PURSUING INOTES DOCKS NATIONS
PER SE IN THIS CASES WERE
REFERRED TO BACK THE NATION'S
WE WANT THAT- YOU KNOW SOME
PEOPLE WANT ONE TO LET OTHER
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GETTING VACCINATED OTHERPEOPLE
WANT TO BE DISCREET A PRIVATE
ABOUT IT I THINK WE NEED TO
RESPECT THAT- UNDECIDED BUT
ALSO FOR HEALTH REASONS AND
THAT GOES FOR ANY OF OUR- OUR-
OUR- ELEMENTS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
BUT ALSO. NOT NOT SAYING THAT
WE YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
EXPRESS AN ASSEMBLE BUT GIVING
THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
AS WELL AND I THINK THIS BILL
DOESN'T TELL YOU THAT YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO- IS JUST SAYING
THAT. WE NEED A LITTLE BIT OF A
PRIVACY BUFFER ON THAT END AND
IF THERE IS- IN THE LEAD
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE I WOULD.
BE VERY VERY ADAM CURIOUS TO
HEAR THEIR THOUGHTS SIR. AM I
ABLE TO RESPOND- MISTER CHAIR.
R. YES RUNNING A ONE RESPONSE
TO THAT TOO- IS IT TOO. WELL I
CERTAINLY IF I MAY I DO THESE
DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. WON'T TAKE YOUR
REYNOLDS AGAIN WHAT WOULD BE
WHAT WOULD BE NIGHT RESPONSIBLE.
THANK SO USUALLY WERE ON THE
SIDEWALK NEAR AN ENTRANCE OR
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING AND
WE HAVE SIGNS THAT ARE ARE
LETTING THEM KNOW ABOUT THINGS
THAT THEY PROBABLY DON'T
ALREADY KNOW. AND WE HAVE
LITERATURE TO- TO GIVE THEM
MORE INFORMATION SO THREE
HUNDRED FEET REALLY COMPLETELY
GETS US OUT OF- THE- LIKE WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO BE ACROSS
THE STREET. SO IT WOULD BE HARD
FOR US TO I SEE TARGET TO ME
BECAUSE OUR GOAL IS OBVIOUSLY
TO GIVE INFORMATION TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE COMING TO GET
VACCINATED IF WE WERE ABLE TO
BE ACROSS THE STREET. THE WE
WE'VE MUCH FURTHER AWAY
NOBODY'S CELL PHONES GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SHOW ANYBODY'S FACE
IN EVERYBODY'S FACES IS PRETTY
MUCH MASTERED THEIR CARS I MEAN
WHEN THEY'RE COMING INTO A
COVER NINETEEN VACCINATION SITE
ALMOST EVERYBODY HAS A MASK ON
IN THEIR CAR SO THEIR
IDENTITIES. REALLY I THINK
ALREADY PROTECTED BUT- THE
THREE HUNDRED FEET THING IS
GOING TO KEEP US FROM EVEN
BEING ACROSS THE STREET WHICH
PUTS US WAY FAR OUT TO A POINT
WHERE IT'S HARD FOR US TO GET
THIS INFORMATION TO THE PEOPLE
COMING IN TO GET VACCINATED.
SEVEN MARCH TWENTY MILLION
THIRTY SECONDS. THE SUPREME
COURT HAS STRUCK DOWN THIRTY
FIVE POINT BUFFER ZONES AROUND
ABORTION CLINICS SO THE DEAD
THREE HUNDRED FIVE BUFFER ZONE
IS VERY LEGALLY PROBLEMATIC.
I'M SORRY ONE MORE TIME. TO SET
TO SEPARATE ORDER STRUCK DOWN A
THIRTY FOOT BUFFER AT A PORTION
CLINICS AND USES THREE HUNDRED
FEET IS PROBLEMATIC. OKAY I
WOULD SENATOR PAN DO YOU HAVE
ANY- I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS
AS YOUR FEEDBACK AS TO AS TO
THAT PERSPECTIVE THAT POINT I
JUST POINT OUT THAT- THAT
ACTUALLY- FOR ALL THE CLAIMS OF
THIS BEING A CONSTITUTIONAL
ACTUALLY- IT'S- SOME OF US HAVE
BEEN UPHELD BY THE COURTS-
NGUYEN ANTI GAY PROTESTERS THE
DISTRIBUTED AT FUNERALS FOR
FAMILY FOR MILITARY MEMBERS.
AND SAID THEIR BUFFER ZONES
HAVE BEEN HELPFUL FOR BRICK AND
MORTAR CLINICS- SO CERTAINLY-
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS PREVENT
DISRUPTION RIGHT SO IT'S NOT
ABOUT SPEECH ABOUT THIS
RUCTIONS YOU POINTED OUT WE
SHOULDN'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO BULLY
AND INTIMIDATE AND- OF THE
STRIP ABSTRACT SO WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE BEING SCARED AWAY FROM
VACCINATION CLINICS BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID THEY'RE GOING TO
BE HARASSED- THE CHECK OUT THE
PICTURES TAKEN- THAT- DIDN'T
HAVE TO BE UP THEIR PERSONAL
IDENTITIES EXPOSED. TO- JUST
FOR TRYING TO GET TO A
VACCINATION SITE. AND THAT'S
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL. I
THINK BURKE. CHAIR I THINK I
JUST ON THE CURFEW. PART OF IT
AS FAR AS THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THIRTY FIVE. FOOT- WHAT A
WHAT IS YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT END. BUT I THINK THE ISSUE
IS GOING TO BE- ESPECIALLY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
DIFFERENT SITES SO FOR AND
AGAIN WHETHER- AND FOR
CERTAINLY THE OPPOSING CLAIMS
YES STRONGLY RECOMMEND PEOPLE
BE MASKS BUT THERE'S A VERY
DIFFERENT WAYS I MEAN EVEN WITH
THE MASK YOU CAN STILL IDENTIFY
PEOPLE- DEPENDING ON THE ANGLE
AND HOW CLOSE YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
GET TO PEOPLE IN THE USED
TELEPHOTO LENS IT CETERA. SO WE
WANT ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
EXPRESS YOUR VIEWS AT THINK AS
YOU SAID- CENTER THAT. THIS IS
pPEOPLE FOR EXPRESSING THEIR
POINTS OF VIEW IT'S ABOUT BEING
SURE THAT PEOPLE DO NOT GET
BULLIED OR HARASSED IN TRYING
TO GET. THEIR VACCINES. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A TYPE OF
TACTICS THAT WE SAW IN DODGERS
STADIUM AND THOSE ARE TYPES
TACTICS YOU SEE THEM TRY TO
POST ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THEY
WANT TO DO- INCLUDING MISTER
COLEMAN HERE. SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT. OUR THERE'S A QUESTION
OR CONCERN TO ALL RIGHT-
DOCTRINE TOWARD CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIR BRADFORD-
I FIND IT QUITE TELLING THAT
THE LEAD WITNESSES ACTUALLY A
MAN WHO I NOT ONLY- HAS-
PERSONALLY ACTUALLY FOLLOWED ME
HER PERSONALLY TO. NOT ONLY
HERE IN THE CAPITAL BY THE WAY
AND SCOTT AND CERTAINLY MUCH
CLOSER TO THIRTY FIVE FEET
RIGHT UP IN MY FACE- BUT ALSO
AS TRAVEL TO NEW YORK IN DC AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
PERSONALLY HARASSED ME BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT ME.
THIS IS ABOUT VACCINATION SITES
AND SO- I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
HE THAT WE DO HAVE A PLANS FROM
PEOPLE INCLUDING ACTION MISTER
COLEMAN TO TRY TO GO TO
VACCINATION SITES AND- IT'S AND
BASICALLY- CAUSE TROUBLE AND SO
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE-
PROTECT. PEOPLE WHEN THEY GO TO
THE VACCINATIONS- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO WORK VERY HARD TO
PROTECT OUR TO ME THEY TALKED
ABOUT. THE ROLE OF VACCINATIONS
BRING US HOPE. BECAUSE HOPE SO
THAT WE CAN. GET THEY'LL REOPEN
OUR BUSINESSES GET OUR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL SO THAT WE CAN
GO AND BE ABLE TO VISIT OUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILIES. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT SO
WE WANT TO BEGIN THE COULD USE
ITS DOES MENTION. NO WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO RESTRICT ANYONE'S
SPEECH. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS WE'RE TRYING TO SUPPORT THE
RIGHT OF PEOPLE TO BE SAFE TO
GET ACCESS TO VACCINES IF THEY
CHOOSE TO DO SO. AND NOT TO BE
BULLIED OR TERMINATED- FROM
GETTING A VACCINE THAT THEY
HAVE CHOSEN TO GET. A WITH THAT
ARE STRICTLY ASPEN I WROTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER WE HAVE A DO
PASS TO RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY MADAM. CHILDREN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. S. SEVEN
FOUR TWO PAN- DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SHOW ABOVE. SHOW
THE OF NOT THE NO NO. GIVE ME
ONE SECOND. PONDERING HERE.
SORRY KAMLAGER I AM LONGER ICE
SKINNER WIENER WIENER AYE AT
SHOWBOAT. I'M GONNA GO WITH HI
SHOBO GUY. IT'S GOT FOUR VOTES
FROM HOLD FOR SKINNER MEASURES
FOR VOTE TO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO. I AM TOO I DON'T SEE
CENTER PORTANTINO. HI. ON MARCH
I WILL DO MY MORE ON MEASURE.
HI- FILE ITEM READ. THREE FOUR
NINE THREE THIRTY THREE WITH
MEMBERS I WILL HAVE TO GO OVER
TO OUR VICE YEAR. SIR. I THINK.
FOUR NINETY THREE. WELCOME
SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL ON SB FOUR
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU TO YOUR
ARMS AS BEFORE NINETY THREE.
PROMOTING YOU SUCCESS AND
EMPOWERMENT BETTER KNOWN AS THE
PROBLEMS ACTORS FEEL WILL BRING
US TO REFORM TO JUVENILE
JUSTICE CRIME PREDICTION
PREVENTION ACT. BY DOING A
VARIETY OF THINGS IT WILL
DIRECT 95% OF THE FUN FROM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT OR JJ CPA. TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NON LAW ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC
AGENCIES INSURERS ARE CRUEL
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION IN
DECISION MAKING PROCESS BY
REQUIRING AT LEAST 50% OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCIL TO BE NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY AND IT WILL
STRENGTHEN COMMUNITY REPORTING
AND EVALUATION PROCESS TO
INCLUDE. CRITICAL EVIDENCE ON
UCHE SERVED AND PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND A JUVENILE JUSTICE
CRIME PREVENTION AT HAS BEEN
STEADY SOURCE OF FUNDING TO
ASSIST COUNTIES AND REDUCING
CRIME ALONG. ARE YOU THE J. J.
C. P. A. ALSO REQUIRES EACH
COUNTY TO ESTABLISH A JUVENILE
JUSTICE COORDINATING COUNCIL
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
DELYLAH DEVELOPING A
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI AGENCY
JUVENILE JUSTICE PLAN LAST YEAR
THE STATE AUDITORS AUDITOR
FINISHED CONDUCTING AN AUDIT TO
ASSESS THE SPENDING AND
REPORTING OF J. J. C. P. A.
FUNDS IN FIVE COUNTIES DAUGHTER
FILED SERIOUS PROBLEMS
INCLUDING- WITH REPORTING
PLANNING AND COUNCIL
MEMBERSHIP. TODAY COUNTIES
CONTINUE TO EXPAND THEIR
MAJORITY OF THEIR FONTS ON
PROBATION. WITH MOST OF THE
FUNDS GOING TOWARD PROBATION
DEPARTMENT STAFFING A LITTLE
SPENT ON COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THIS BILL ONLINE
JG CPA'S SPINNING WITH THE TO
REJECT ORIGINAL INTENT TO
GRANT. A GRAND I SHOULD SAY TO
SUPPORT YOUTH AND REDUCE
INVOLVEMENT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THROUGH COLLABORATIVE
AND COMMUNITY LED EFFORTS IT
WILL ALSO ADDRESS LONGSTANDING
PROBLEMS WITH GRANTS
ADMINISTRATION AND REPORTING TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE DOLLARS
ARE BEING EFFECTIVELY USED AND
MANAGED- I KNOW THEIR
OPPOSITION HAS SEVERAL CONCERNS
REGARDING CHANGING YOUR POLLS-
A PROPOSED. IN THIS BILL. OUR
STATE REGARDING CHANGES THAT
ARE PROPOSED IN THIS BILL I
WANT TO COMMEND THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT WE SHARE THE GOALS
OF DIVERTING ARE YOU FROM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER THE TREND WE SEE NOW OF
DECLINING USE CRIME ARE NOT THE
RESULT OF SOLELY PROBATION OR
ANY SINGLE DEPARTMENT OR POLICY
CHANGE VARIOUS FACTORS
INCLUDING IMPROVEMENT OF
EDUCATION IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
SECOND CONTRIBUTE TO THIS JUST
FOR THE CLIENT- STUDIES
NUMEROUS STUDIES EXPERTS IN
TESTIMONY FROM ARE YOU SHOW HOW
EFFECTIVE THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
ONE FOCUSED ON THE COMMUNITY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTIES IMPROVE PATIENT
PARLIAMENT TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. AND TESTIFYING HERE
TODAY IS CAN'T MENDOZA WHOSE TO
ANTI RECIDIVISM RECIDIVISM
COALITION ARE BETTER KNOWN AS
ARC. AND RENAME MEN ARE AT THE
CENTER FOR JUVENILE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. AND THEY'RE ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I REQUEST
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR BRADFORD AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE. WITH
OUR. OUR LEAD SUPPORT WHICH-
MISTER CAN MENDOZA ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES SIR WE CAN PLEASE PROCEED.
OKAY GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KEN MENDOZA ON THE ADVOCATE THE
MANAGER FOR THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I SPENT FIVE YEARS IN
CULTURE FROM DAY DISAPPEAR INTO
THE TWENTY AND COMING HOME AND
TALKING TO FOURTEEN I HAVE BEEN
LEADING TE EFFORT TO IMPROVE
OUR LOCAL JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. ANY COUNTIES YOU'RE
GONNA GET THIS COORDINATED
CONSISTENT PLUS IN AN EIGHTEEN
DIDN'T GET YOU TO SEE HAS BEEN
OVERSEEING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THIRTY TO FIFTY MILLION DATING
SHOULD BE EIGHT DOLLARS
ANNUALLY UNFORTUNATELY PRIOR TO
ME GOING INTO THE BODY AND IN
RECENT YEARS L. A. COUNTY HAD
BEEN UNDER FIRE FOR ITS
INEFFECTIVE DAY GET TO CREATE
ADMINISTRATION- BAD ANY CUT
ALMOST THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
UNSPENT. NEGATIVE GRADE
DAUGHTER CAN TIGHTEN SIXTEEN
AND MUCH OF THE FUNDS THAT WERE
USED WENT STRAIGHT TO CROATIAN
STAFFING AND PROGRAMS THAT
ULTIMATELY HURT GET THE COLOR.
OUT OF FUN LITTLE EVIDENCE THAT
ANY OF THESE SPENDING WERE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND IMPROVING YOUR
OUTCOMES DURING THAT TIME THE
JTCC FUNCTIONALITY RUBBER
STAMPING BECAUSE THIS PUTTING
TAUGHT IN AN EIGHTEEN WHEN I
WAS APPOINTED ALONG WITH NINE
OTHER COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVE.
WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE IT A MORE
EQUITABLE BODY ASKING HOW THE
ADDED COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES
HAVE HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT. L.
A. COUNTY NOT A BIG IT
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI AGENCY
GIVEN THE DEATH THIS GRANT
ANNUALLY SOMETHING THAT MANY
OLDER CHINESE CALL SHORT OF
REFLECTING AND. OUT. WE HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. ARE CURRENTLY CHAIRED
BY REPUBLICAN OUT THERE. AND
MOST OF THE DECISION MAKING
HAPPENED IN THE PARISIAN
APARTMENTS WITHOUT INPUT FROM
OTHERS. HIS BILL REQUIRED THAT
AT LEAST HALF OF THE DAY IF YOU
SEE MEMBERS. AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT REQUIRES THAT ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND LIKE THE
CULTURE. CONTENT THE COMMUTER
REPRESENTATION WILL HELP
COUNTRIES MEET GET GET YOU
GREAT GOALS AND EVENT AND HELP
FOCUS. COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THE MOST URGENT NEED
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. AFFECTED
WHEN IT STARTED WHEN HE COULD
HAVE DECISION MAKING AND WHAT
YOUR VOTE HERE TODAY. I
RESPECTFULLY. I BOTH ON CENTER
BILL OR NINETY THREE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MENDOZAFOR YOUR- TESTIMONY WE
WILL GO TO A ART IF YOU ARE ON
THE LINE DO WE HAVE A NAME
MINARD ONLINE. OKAY IN THE
ESSENCE OF TIME WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO WITNESSES HERE
IN A ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THAT MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR NINETY THREE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT
OF FOUR NINETY THREE. C. NINE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
NINETY THREE. CNN LET ME GIVE
ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE IF
RENAME IN ART IS ON THE LINE.
OKAY RAYMOND ARE IF YOU ARE ON
THE LINE PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO
AND WE WILL OPEN YOUR LINE. IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ON THE LINE AS
OF YET LET'S- IN THE ESSENCE OF
TIME WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON. ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME. YES HIS ATTITUDE RENEE
MANNER WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HI PLEASE PROCEED I BELIEVE I
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M BURNING MAN ART
COMMUNICATIONS AND POLICY
ANALYST AT THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
COULD YOU DO TO PAY EVEN
ONGOING INVESTMENT WHICH
RENEWED IMPORTANCE AMID STATE
BUDGET STRAIN AND CALLS TO
ADDRESS HARM AT THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTICULARLY IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR EACH YEAR
COUNTY RECEIVE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF JJ DPA DOLLARS
WITHOUT PROPER OVERSIGHT.
CONCERNED ABOUT PROBLEMATIC
EIGHTY P. EXPANDING LED TO A
STATE AUDIT RELEASED LAST MAY
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
COUNTY HAS FAILED TO
DEMONSTRATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THEIR GPA FUNDED. PROGRAMS
ALONGSIDE. AB ONE WITH COUNCIL.
WITH COORDINATING MEMBER AND-
ADDITIONALLY INSUFFICIENT
REPORT BY TO BE A AND COUNTY.
LEGISLATORS AND THE PUBLIC THE
DARK. T. PAY SPENDING HAVEN'T
CAL UP WITH ME DECLINES IN RAP
DROPPING EIGHT THREE PER SINCE
TWO THOUSAND. AND YOU COME IN
DRY IN USE APPROACH PROBATION.
ACCORDING TO NOT ACTUAL
PROBATION COOPER OFTEN. FURTHER
INTO THE SYSTEM YET ARE NOW A
FISCALLY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ON THE ON AVERAGE
COUNTY SPENT 72% OF JJ OKAY
FINE ON SALARIES AND BENEFITS
PRIMARILY FOR PROBATION STAFF
WITH MANY SPENDING FAR MORE. ON
AVERAGE ONLY SPENT 15% OF
ALLOTTED FUNDS ON SERVICES RUN
BY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH ABOUT HALF
OF COUNTIES. NO MONEY ON TV
ABOUT ALL ALL OF THIS RUNS
COUNTER TO THE ORIGINAL INTENT
FOR THIS GRANT TO INVEST IN
COLLABORATIVE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES REDUCE AND PREVENT
YOUTH INVOLVEMENT IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. SB FOUR NINETY
THREE WILL REVITALIZED JJ BACK
MEANT BY REDIRECTING 95% OF
FINES TO EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS
OFFERED BY CBO IT'S A NORMAL
APPOINTMENT PUBLIC AGENCIES.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE CAN
CORRECT COURSE AND PRIORITIZE
USED DEVELOPMENT HEALTH
EDUCATION AND EMPOWERMENT WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON. IT BEFORE NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MISS MINARD- WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE ON OUR WITNESSES WE
TO TEST VIA THE TELE. IS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PUMP THE-
WILLING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FOUR NINETY THREE AND
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN PRESS ONE NOT THEM
THERE- IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS CAITLYN D. N. H. L. U.
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD SPONSOR
TO SEE THE COMMITTEES TIME TO
CO SPONSORS ARE CONSOLIDATED A
LIST OF NEEDS YOUR SUPPORT
AFTER FOLLOWING. ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ARCH FOR
HEALING AND JUSTICE NETWORK AND
THE RPG WHICH ACTION CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUSTICE. CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE CAMP
GILBOA CHILDREN NOW SHOULD
CORPS. CLERGY AND LAITY UNITED
FOR ECONOMIC JUSTICE CLUB
STRIDING COALITION FOR ENGAGED
EDUCATION. COURAGE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
EMPOWERING THE CIVIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES. EVERY CHILD
FOUNDATION SHARE CHANCE PROJECT
IN FAMILIES UNITED TO END A
LONG. RIDGE CENTER FREEDOM FOR
YOU. KNOW PART OF THE NEEDLES.
FRIEND COMMITTEE LEGISLATION
AND CALIFORNIA. GANG AWARENESS
AND PREVENTION GAP CHILLING
DIALOGUE AND ACTION. HOME BOYS
INDUSTRIES HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNERS INITIATE CHAPTER
JOURNEY HOW LA FORWARD LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN MONTEREY COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S NATIONAL JUVENILE
JUSTICE NETWORK PUBLIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER. REVOLUTION
PEOPLE CITY COUNCIL PUBLIC
COUNCIL SECRET HEART COMMUNITY
SERVICE. FOR YOU SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC TO. SHE. NINE EIGHT FIVE
AIRLINERS ALL. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE US SOLELY SHOT
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER CALLERS. SUPPORT OF
S. B. LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE P.
SHARE CAR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU. MY NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MIGUEL GARC
HERE ABOUT COSPONSORED WITH
ANTI REPUBLICAN COALITION AND A
RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WELL I NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I GET UP IN A CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
FUNDING IS WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE COALITION PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU. PINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SACRAMENTO
GUARDED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
NINE NINE NINE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. INTERVIEWS
FRAZIER WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAU CRATER
WITHIN THE ARC JEWISH ACTION
CALIFORNIA ALONGSIDE FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN BANYAK
MEMBERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
IN STRONG SUPPORT IN AN EFFORT
TO SAVE TIME WILL SEND A LIST
OF ALL THE NAMES OF INDIVIDUALS
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE
THREE WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY TO SHARE THEIR ME TOO.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. BY NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS LAURA RIDOLFI WITH THE W.
HAYWOOD BURNS INSTITUTE A PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MY NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE FIFTEEN YEAR GAP THE
CALLING FROM THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB FOUR
NINETY THREE AND OFFERING
ACROSS THE BOARD THANK YOU. BY
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME AGAIN VOLATILITY
THE COALITION LOCAL SPONSOR AND-
IN SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY FIVE
AIRLINERS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MADISON DO COSTS WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING INTO WORK THANK
YOU. SCHLINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALSO FOR THE STATE
PRISON FOR LACK OF FUNDING
SINCE STRONG SUPPORT AS A
COMMUNITY MEMBER. AND AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. NINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI NICOLE BROWN WITH THE URBAN
PEACE INSTITUTE IN LOS ANGELES
AND WORKING IN CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ERIC MORSE
AND ALL TO MAKE A BEELINE
SUPPORT MEDICAL- WE'RE
COSPONSORED AND STRONG
SUPPORTER SB. FOUR NINE THREE.
AT NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CLEAN THAT WOULD NEED THE
UNITED FOR A THIRD OF YOU JUST
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE P. FOUR NINE THREE FOR MUCH
MUCH. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OF OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR S. B. FOR NINETY
THREE PLEASE. CERTAINLY AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOUR IN
SUPPORT ONE MINUTE THEN. ZERO
M. LINE EIGHTY SIX CAROLINA'S
OPEN. GOOD MORNING AGAIN I JUST
WANTED TO- COMPLETE THE LIST OF
ME TOOS- STARTING WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
SOCIAL DROP THE CORNING INC IF
YOU. AWAKENING FOUNDATION
STARTING OVER INC FROM THANK
YOU. SAN FRANCISCO THE
GATHERING FOR JUSTICE THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM THE UNITY
COUNCIL THE YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER ON COMMON LAW
UNDERGROUND GREAT. WHAT ABOUT
THE COUNSELING CENTER WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK WHITE. WOMEN
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA YOU ALIVE
YOU FORWARD AND YOU CATCH UP
THE EDUCATION CLINIC LOYOLA.
LAW SCHOOL THANK YOU. AND I
KNOW OTHER LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR-
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION- RIGHT NOW WE DO
HAVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE HAVE. JOSH ROGER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
THEN THE L. SANCHEZ FROM CHEAP
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA- MISTER DOCTOR ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I AM PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS JOSH
DUGGAR REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
WITH URBAN AND RURAL COUNTY
FOLLOW ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT
THE CONTINUED EVALUATION OF THE
BEST ANDMOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF USING OUR
COMMUNITY WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB FOUR NINETY THREE.
ASSEMBLY CUT WITHIN STRIKING
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT OF
95% OF A LONGSTANDING FUNDING
STREAM WILL PROVIDE GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY OR IMPROVE THE
CONTINUUM OF RESPONSES TO OR
PREVENTION OF. JUVENILE CRIME
AND DELINQUENCY. WE ALSO WANT
TO BE THAT THE UNDER REPORT
DOES NOT. REDIRECTING FUNDS
AWAY FROM PROBATION APARTMENTS
JUST BECAUSE THE SAMPLE COUNTY
USED A HIGH PROPORTION ON
PROBATION LED INTERVENTION.
ACTUALLY THOUGHT IT DOES QUITE
THE OPPOSITE BY RECOMMENDING
THE STATE INCREASED ANNUAL
FUNDING TO COUNTIES FOR THIS
PROGRAM. ALSO RESPECTFULLY
REJECT THE NOTION THAT COUNTY
IMPLEMENT. HAS BEEN
INCONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF JJ CPA. OR PUBLISHED
YET COUPLE YEARS AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION BY THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON JUVENILE
JUSTICE. AND CHAIR AND AUTHOR
OF THE BILL ESTABLISHING JJ PPA
IS OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
COUNTY THAN COMPENSATION DOES
NOT MENTION THE NEED TO
REDIRECT THE FUNDS BUT DOES
INDICATE COUNTY. INVESTED FUNDS
BROADLY ACROSS TOWN YOU RUN
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THROUGH
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH VIDEOS.
CONDITIONALLY WE BELIEVE THE
PROPOSED CHANGES IN THIS BILL
DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT
CHANGES THAT HAVE OCCURRED
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN TWO
THOUSAND. AND TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THE PROGRAM AND FUNDING
STRUCTURE WAS MOVED UNDER THE
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN PUBLIC
SPEAKING REWINDING ON BROADWAY.
AND PROTECTED BY THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISIONS OF
PROPOSITION THIRTY. PROGRAMS
NOW FUNDED WITH VEHICLE LICENSE
FEE REVENUE IN THE COUNTY
MOBILE RUNNING FINE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. IS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE BECAUSE
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
PROPOSITION THIRTY AND ARTICLE
THIRTEEN SECTION THIRTY SIX OF
THE CONSTITUTION. THE MONEY IN
EACH COUNTY LOCAL REVENUE FUND
SHALL BE EXCLUSIVELY YEARS
DEFINING THE PROVISION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. ARE SPECIFIED BY THE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN RELYING
THAT LEGISLATION. SOME THIRTY
BROADLY TO PUBLIC THANK YOU SIR
TO GET MAX JUST THE COUNT. AND
ALSO COUNTY FROM IN BECAUSE OR
NOT TO START PLACE ON REALIGNED.
WHICH IS WHY CHANGE TO G. P.
THANK THAT FIND AT THE END
CAREFUL. WITH DELIBERATE INCOME
FROM THEM PRO APARTMENTS. LAST
ALREADY. PROVIDED BY PRO MISTER.
TO CRIMINALS AND BY COPY. VALUE
A COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSION ON
IMPROVING ACCESS TO HELP THOSE
EFFORTS BUT THIS BILL DOES NOT
REFLECT. THAT COLLABORATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH
MISTER GOD. WE WILL NOW- AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT. HE LIED
OPPOSITION WITNESS DANIELLE
SANCHEZ ARE YOU ON THE LINE TO
SANCHEZ. I AM GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU- INSURING MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THAT BEFORE NINETY
THREE I WANT TO FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYTHING CANNELLA
BRADFORD AND IT'S OUT FOR THEIR
TIME IN OPENING A DIALOGUE WITH
THAT ON THE ISSUE. WHAT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL I DO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE BILLIONS OF THE
DISCUSSION TO REALLY TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE OF AND
WHERE WE CAN LOOK AT THE
COACHES TO ENHANCING JG EPA YOU
RATHER THAN THE PROHIBITION OF
PROBATE. PROBATION IN
DELIVERING THESE SERVICES TO.
CALIFORNIA HAS COLLECTIVELY
REDUCED USAGE OF OUR LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITIES I SIXTY
PERCENT. EFFECTIVELY SERVES 90%
OF YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE BUT COMPLETELY WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES I NEVER CLEARLY
67% OF YOU TRANSFERRED TO
PROBATION A DECREASE IN
JUVENILE COURT **** JUVENILE
CRIME HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
DECLINE. BUT IT ALSO LARGELY
DRUG BY AT TO PREVENT DIVERSION
CHARM INFORMED APPROACHES AND
AVOIDING THAT DETENTION OF YOU
ARE NON AND. DO YOU EPA WOULD
DEVELOP IN THE MOST ENGINE
APPROACH TO PREVENT JUVENILE
BECOME MORE. IN WITH A THE
SENSE THAT. AS WELL AS TO TURN.
YOU CAN. OUT OF THIS IS ARE
QUITE. COUNTY THE PROBATION
HAVING TO A NEW. OF AGE PART.
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY.
ECOLAB AND NEEDED SERVICES.
HOWEVER IN MANY PROBATION OF
THE SOUL AND FROM AT THE
SERVICES FOR YOU. IN A TRAIN
OUR OFFICERS AND TO BE A
SERVICE PROVIDER AND DELIVER
THE ADVOCATE FROM. PROGRAMMING
IS EXPECTED TRAINING ALLOW
TRACK DELIVER THESE- PROGRAMS
AND- BUT CONSISTENCY THE DALLAS
THE AND ENSURE PRO MEETS THE
RIGOROUS. LAID OUT BY AND READ.
TO THAT END IT IS ON WHY THE OF
COULD BE AND BE PROPOSED UNDER
BEFORE NINETY THREE RATHER THAN
MAKING. BECAUSE AND DEVELOP OF
LOCAL. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
WE THE TO THE- OF THE JEFF
COURTNEY COUNTY. WE CERTAINLY
IT. THE BENEFIT OF HAVING MORE
PERSPECTIVES ON THIS CAN TO THE
A LOWER PLAN. WE DO WANT TO
POINT OUT HOWEVER THERE ARE.
WITHIN THE CAN COMPANY. THAT
PROVISION PASSED OUT TWO AND
PROJECT. FROM ALL NAY. THERE
HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES DOING. BY
RICK. RATHER OFFERING ADDITION
MEMBERS IN THE- ACCOUNT AND.
LASTLY I WOULD NOTE THAT COUNTY
THEIR CURRENT WORK TO DO THAT
VERY ROBUST LOCAL TRANSCEND. I
DID TAKING ON THE RISK TO OF
SERVING YOUTH THAT WOULD
FORMALLY AND- DI. REMOVING THE
CHEAPER THE OFFICER AT THE
CHAIR THE ACCOUNT. WILL HAVE
BROUGHT INPUT AND PLAN
ACCORDING. AND ULTIMATELY BE A
TO THE HIGH NEED TO THREATENS.
DO YOU THINK ANY PART OF THE-
ON JEOPARDY ALL. STATE FROM.
THE NEEDED SIR. AND SUPPORT AT
YOU CAN EVERYONE. IN WE STRONG
SUPPORT CONTINUED EVOLUTION AND
A VALUE. OF OUR- JUSTICE. OUR
G. POCKET IN THAT HISTORY OF
THE ON THE OR REALLY REFLECT
THAT. HOWEVER IMPORT INVESTMENT
IN LOCAL WOULD CREATE A THE FOR
THE PROVISION AND SUPPORT OF
AND HOW CAN YOU. THAT WE WERE
VERY COMMITTED TO BE THE PARTY
COMP. AND YOU- AND HOW THAT TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE INFORMED
AND EVIDENCE APPROACH. TO
SUPPORTING BOTH YOU AND THE
FAMILIES ABOUT THIRTY THREE
MUCH OPPOSE THAT POINT THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY. THE
LIST. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM. FORTY WISH
TO TEST UP WITH OF FIVE NINETY.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE.
C. NINE. I WILL GO ON TO MOVE
TO WITNESSES. S. B. TWENTY
FORTY I'M SORRY INCOME TWENTY
FORTY. C. NINE- THING YOU AND
I'M ON TO A. WAITING TESTIFY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- MADAM BY SURE MISTER
CHAIRMAN CENTER BRADFORD DISS
ALBERTO TRICO IN OPPOSITIONIST
BEFORE NINETY THREE AND A HALF
OF THE STATE PUSH A PROBATION
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO WANT ON
THANK THE AUTHOR TO STAFF FOR
WILLING TO TALK TO US AND TRY
TO REACH SOME KIND OF
RESOLUTION ON THIS ISSUE WE
SUPPORT YOUR OBJECTIVES SO FROM
YOU KNOW BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
YOUTH BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
DISRUPT BROTHER BROOCH. THANK
YOU. WHY AND WHY NOT. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS GREG
STEWART PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY PROBATION ASSOCIATION-
HERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
NINETY THREE. NINE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTHEW SYED
RULING ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES PROBATION OFFICERS YOU
JUST ASKED WE LOOK AT FIVE ECHO
THE COMIC MISTER TRIGO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU I
AND OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
WITH CBO'S BUT WOULD- THE
REQUESTED WE- WILL EXPLORE THIS
FURTHER AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A PARTNERSHIP- IN IT
BUT IT COULD. YUP CONTINUED.
BUT PRINT PROBATION IS PROCESS
THANK YOU WHAT. CHEN AGAIN
APPEALING WAY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
THERE AT THIS ONE OF THEM
THEY'RE ALL. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE LEFT IN KILL.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO I HEAR FROM ALL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. FOUR NINE THREE. AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE OF
THEM THEY'RE ALL. AND THERE IS
NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR- WE
WANT TO THANK ALL OUR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. STE THUNDERSTORMS I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE HAVE SENATOR BRAD
FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I WANNA FREE SHOOT
BOTH OF THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND- I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
HERE AS WE MOVE FOR WITH THIS.
MEASURE BUT I THINK WE ALL ON
BOTH SIDES WANT TO THE DESIRED
OUTCOME OF HELPING OUR YOUTH-
FIRST OF LLOYD- THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SYSTEM BUT THOSE
WHO FIND THEMSELVES AND IT HAS-
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT-
THIS BILL WILL ON. THE PROGRAM
WAS INITIALLY DESIGNED TO DO
AND I WAS TO DIVERT- DIRECT
ACTION AND INTERACTION I SHOULD
SAY WITH- LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
AND PROBATION. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE STATED GOAL ON BOTH
SIDES AND- WE WANNA DIRECT
RESPONSE TO COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
THAT HELP- INTEGRATE- THESE
YOUNG FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT ARE OUT
THERE SO THAT'S THE GOAL AND
INTENTION I MAKE THE COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH BOTH
SIDES TO. ACHIEVE THAT DESIRED.
GOAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD-
ADAM CONSULTANCIES CALL THE
ROLL. SB PORT NINETY THREE DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD
ARE BRADFORD AYE CHOI BOGUE NOW
BROUGH NO COM LONGER SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE WIENER. HOLD
WILL BE HOLDING THE ROLE OPEN
UP FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOUBLE PASSED THE
GAVEL BACK TO SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MEMBER BY SHEER NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATOR MEN SB.
SEVEN SIX THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I PROCEED. FIVE
THIRTY MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP SEVEN SIXTY THREE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW A DEFENDANT
WHO IS A VETERAN OR MILITARY
MEMBER AND SUFFERING FROM A
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM AS A
RESULT OF THEIR MILITARY
SERVICE TO PETITION FOR RECALL
OF THE SENTENCE AND FOR
RESENTENCING WITHOUT REGARD TO
THE DATE OF THE ORIGINAL
SENTENCE. THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THIS RELIEF IS
AVAILABLE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WAS AN ARGUMENT MADE OR
EVIDENCE PRESENTED. AT THE
TRIAL OF TRIAL ABOUT THE
DEFENDANT'S SERVICE RELATED
CONDITION. CURRENTLY ONLY
VETERANS AND SERVICEMEN AND
MEMBERS SENTENCED PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN HAVE THIS PROCEDURAL
RIGHT- A SITUATION THAT FAILS
TO ENSURE EQUAL TREATMENT OF
ALL VETERANS AND MILITARY
MEMBERS WITH SERVICE RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR STATE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE GOODWIN
LIU CALLED FOR RENEWED
LEGISLATIVE ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. IN A CONCURRING
STATEMENT IN THE PEOPLE VERSUS
VALIANT OPINION. JUSTICE LITTLE
POINTED OUT THE CURRENT SCIENCE
RECOGNIZES PTSD CAN TAKE TIME
TO FULLY MANIFEST PARTICULARLY
FOR VETERANS. RENDON NOTED THAT
TREMENDOUS BACKLOGS AT THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN
AFFAIRS ARE OFTEN A BARRIER TO
VETERANS AND ESTABLISHING THAT
THEY HAVE A SERVICE CONFLATED
CONDITION OR DISABILITY.
ACCORDING TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RIVER EIGHTEEN REPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES. MORE
THAN THREE QUARTERS OF
INCARCERATED VETERANS WHO WERE
HONORABLY DISCHARGED. MOREOVER
INCARCERATED VETERANS WERE
TWICE AS LIKELY AS NON VETERANS
TO REPORT HAVING A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL TELL THEM
THEY HAD PTSD. MORE GENERALLY
ABOUT HALF OF INCARCERATED VETS
HAVE BEEN TOLD THEY HAVE A
MENTAL DISORDER OR ILLNESS BY
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AND OF THESE. THREE VETERANS
WHO HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED OVER
60% HAD BEEN CAUGHT IN COMBAT.
SB SEVEN SIXTY THREE IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO AB
FIVE EIGHTY ONE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. A BILL THAT
HAD BIPARTISAN BROAD SUPPORT IN
LEGISLATURE AND WAS UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ENSURES THAT
THE STATE IS ACKNOWLEDGING THE
ROLE THAT SERVICE RELATED
MENTAL ILLNESS CAN PLAY IN
FELONY OFFENSES COMMITTED BY
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS AND
VETERANS- THIS TRIES TO PROVIDE
A MEANINGFUL PROCESS FOR THOSE
WHO SERVED OUR COUNTRY. AND ARE
SUFFERING FROM THE CONSEQUENCES
THEREOF- TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
THE NEED FOR SB SEVEN SIXTY
THREE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
JUSTICE I LEAN MORE. ON
APPELLATE JUSTICE. ALSO A
VETERAN COMBAT NURSE IN OUR
PREVIOUS YEAR AND THE CHAIR OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
VETERANS. IN THE COURT AND
MILITARY FAMILY SUBCOMMITTEE I
ALSO HAVE RON SELF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF VETERANS
HEALING VETERANS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR MAN WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES DO WE HAVE- JUSTINA I
LEAN MORE. ONLINE THIS IS
SCHERING RILEY ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. UNFORTUNATELY
JUSTICE BORIS HEARING ORAL
ARGUMENTS AT THE TIME SO I WILL
BE PRESENTING ON HER BEHALF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL- WILL BE
FORMALLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WHEN ARE LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE MEETING. THURSDAY WE
HAVE- PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTED ALL
THE- EFFORTS IN THIS ARENA SO
AT THIS TIME I'M GOING TO MOVE
ON TO JUSTICE MOORE'S STATEMENT
ABOUT. THE OKAY YES PLEASE.
OKAY YEAH I'M SORRY. I'M HAVING
A LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY
AND HEAR ME YES MA'AM. OKAY SO-
HERE IN HER STATEMENT I AM
JUSTIFIED READ MORE I DID ON
THE FOURTH DISTRICT COURT OF
APPEAL IN A PARALYZED A THIRD
OF THE COMBAT NURSE IN VIETNAM
I AM A LIFE MEMBER OF VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA. THE MODEL
OF THE V. A. IS NEVER GAMBLE
ONE EDGE THE VETERANS ABANDONED
ANOTHER ONE MOMENT VETERANS TO
SERVE IN IRAQ GET LIVE HERE ON
CALIFORNIA STREET I BECAME
IMMEDIATELY CONCERNED THAT OUR
WORK BETTER AND MIGHT BE.
TREATED THE SAME RESPECTABLE
MANNER THAT OUR VIETNAM THAT
WEREN'T. BOB NATURE OF AB THE
DEA COUNTY BEFORE. A SEPARATE
TO VOTE TO INVOLVING. VETERANS
AFFAIRS QUALIFYING COURT I HAVE
THE DIVISIONAL COME. TO ON THAT
BECAUSE IN MILAN BAY FAMILIES
FIND. WHEN NO CODE. COLLECTED A
LOT OF KNOW ONE SIX VEHICLE
AUTHORED TWO THOUSAND. FOURTEEN
MY COUNTRY REVIEW THAT. WE
REVIEWED IT AGAIN- WHEN THE
BILL WILL- BE AMENDED BUT THE
TOP ONE AND- FROM TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY SIX PEOPLE PERSONAL
PHONE LINE WE LEARNED IT FROM
THE EFFECT PDF OR OTHER
CONDITION. THAT SHOULD DID NOT
WE STUDIED THE- OR THAT WE BEEN
NOT PREVIOUSLY A- WHEN YOU'RE
READY THOUGHT WITHOUT BUT IT
DID NOT A FIVE TO ACT. SO THAT
VETERANS INSPIRED TO ONE TWENTY
FIFTY NOT A TO. THE COMPANY BUT
BUILT FELT. AND WE CAN ON
VALIANT WITH THAT MARCH TWENTY
HE FOLLOWING QUALIFY HIM. UNDER
THE ORIGINAL HELLO. IT WAS
BECOME TWENTY SEVEN THAT
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
HE DIED THEM WITH P. T. S. B.
IN THE END ALL FOR. UNDER. THE
LAW IT IS THE IN THE QUARTER
APPEAL INVITED THE MY TO RETURN
THE- NOTING THAT VALUE
GENERATION A NEW SHOW ALL BUT-
NOT. INDEED WHEN OF THE GREEN
COURT TO THE- ONE OF THE
DEFENSE AT THE TOOK ME TEN
YEARS OLD STUFF BY THAT TOO
OFTEN BY BERMAN. TO REVISIT
THANK SLEEP THEIR BIG MANY
REASONS FOR DIAGNOSIS PTSD.
VETERAN GET QUALIFY FOR SPEECH.
THE BATTERY BOX AT THE- AT OLE
THE THAT NOT HAVE SIMILAR AIR
THE WITH THE CAN JUST
STOPPARD'S. FIRED ACT COUPLE
COMP HE- MAKE IT BACK. THURMOND
BEEN A DELAY IN THE- WE YOU
MIND CLOSING- TO THE TADIC-
THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO RESULT
BUT PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY IS.
YOU'VE READ THEM- THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOUNG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS VERY FAIR- TIMES THIS
MORNING- DO WE ALSO HAVE- RUNGE
SELF ON THE LINE. YES I'M HERE
PLEASE PROCEED WITH HERSELF.
HELLO AND THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR MEMBERS IN THE BATTLE
CREEK INSPIRATION ON THIS
MATTER- MY NAME IS RON SO OFTEN
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR VETERANS ON VETERANS
I'M ALSO ON HONORABLY
DISCHARGED COMBAT VETERAN
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
EACH TEAM SOCIAL I ALSO SERVE
TWENTY THREE YEARS AND- PRISON.
AND I'M IN FULL SHOULD OF SAN
MEN'S SB SEVEN THREE. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK TO A PERSON
BRIEFLY ANY OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL HELLO TO ASK WHY VETERANS
SHOULD GET A CHANCE. WELL THAT
SIMPLE LESS ONE OF HAVE SERVED
THEM. THAT'S SERVICE AND
ANOTHER WARRANTS CONSIDER FOR
ONE ONE LOOKING. THE NUMBER OF
IN CAR BUT THAT HAVE BEEN
DIRECTING THEM THAT. IN THE
TWENTY THREE YEARS AYE SIR IN
THE PER OF- I LOVE THAT THERE
WERE SIX THOUSAND HUNDRED.
SHOULD THROUGHOUT THIRTY FIVE
PRISON. AND I. BEEN FORTUNATE.
FORTUNATE TO WITH. EIGHT
HUNDRED TO THE AND THE- AND
ALTHOUGH DO I WILL WITH- OF THE
OF THE DOG WITH NOT ONLY THE
BEDROOM. BUT BY THE TIME
MEDICAL OR THE PENAL SYSTEM
WITHIN FINANCE. THREE LOSE
MISTER SELF. MODERATOR THE WE
LOSE OUR- KEY WITNESS
RESTAURANTS SELF. I'M HERE.
HELLO YES HI NOT LIKE YOU'RE
HAVING PHONE PROBLEMS. YES YOU
MIGHT WANT TO JUST REPEAT WHAT
YOU INTENDED TO STATE WITHIN
THE LAST TEN FIFTEEN SECONDS.
MISTER SELF IF YOU CAN HEAR US
I BELIEVE WE'VE LOST YOU AGAIN.
RIGHT BE THAT BAD. JUST MORE.
MISTER SELF HERE AS WORLD COME
BACK TO YOU IN THE ESSENCE OF
TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD TO WITH OUR WITNESSES-
HERE. I'M IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SIX THREE. C. NINE MOVED
TO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WISHES SATISFIED IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIX THREE.
C. NON- MODERATE IF YOU MIND
PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR MISS. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE COUNTY INDIVIDUALS
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SEVEN SIX THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
NINE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ORDER MAMBA HALF OF THE
CAMPING DISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. PINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT YOU KNOW WHICH ONE
YOU ARE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. SO I'M MORE.
IT WILL CRITICALLY WHEN WE A
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES SHOULD I
FINISH WHAT I WAS SAYING-
MISTER SELF YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND YOU MAY FINISH YOUR
STATEMENT. OKAY I WAS JUST
SPEAKING TO THOSE THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL I WOULD
ASK THEM TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE LESS 1% OF
AMERICANS HAVE SERVED IN THE
SERVICE. AND THAT IN AND OF
ITSELF WARRANTS CONSIDERATION
FOR THIS BILL- I WAS ALSO
SPEAKING TO THE FACT THAT I.
FOUNDED IN WORK DIRECTLY WITH
INCARCERATED VETERANS THAT HAVE
PTSD- AND THIS BILL WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT THEM AND
SOCIETY THEY WOULD BE BETTER
SERVED TO SOCIETY NOT IN PERSON
BUT OUT IN COMMUNITY. WORKING
WITH OTHER VETERANS BEFORE THEY
MAKE BAD CHOICES AND DECISIONS.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
SIXTY THREE AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR MISTER
SOUTH FOR YOUR TEST AND THIS
MORNING WE WILL MOVE ON TO AND
CONTINUE WTH OUR- WITNESSES ON
OUR TELECONFERENCE BUSINESS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROCEED PLEASE. THANK YOU WIND
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING IS GREGORY WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING THIS
MADISON DO CARD FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SENATORS MY
NAME IS PLANNED OUT YET
SPEAKING TO A PRIVATE CITIZEN
SHE AND ON BEHALF OF MY SON
ALEXANDER. NONRELIGIOUS US ARMY
SPECIAL FORCES VETERAN.
CURRENTLY SERVING SIX YEAR
RECORD THREE INTRODUCE YA. I AM
IN STRONG HIZO YES ON SB SEVEN
SIX THREE THANK YOU. FIND FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
CALLED HOUSTON THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND- FIND FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE BLIND FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIND FORTY ONE.
EIGHT I ALREADY SPOKE. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU WATER
MARK- MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR SB SEVEN SIX
THREE PLEASE. AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT ONE THAT
THEN. ALL. THE LION FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GUIDED THIS
GUY AGAIN. YEAH AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
HAVING HER FROM ALL OVER
SUPPORT SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE. LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS LARRY MORSE ON THE LINE
AS MISTER MORRIS ARE YOU
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE. MADAM
CHAIR PLEASE PROCEED MISTER
MORRIS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WORRY ON BEHALF OF CAL
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SIX THREE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THE COURTS CONSIDER
VETERANS MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
AFTER SENTENCING UNDER
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES AND
OFFERS A PETITION PROCESS. TO
RECALL A SENTENCE FOR. USUALLY
WHEN CLAIMS ARE NOT RAISED IN
THE TRIAL COURT THEY ARE
FORFEITED EXCEPT UPON A SHOWING
BY FOREVER ALLOWING CLAIMS
WHICH COULD HAVE BEEN TIMELY
MADE BUT WE'RE NOT AND THEN
DISPENSING WITH ANY SHOWING SB
SEVEN SIX THREE UNPRECEDENTED
ALL THAT IS REQUIRED OF THE
POSITION IS AN UNSUBSTANTIATED
ASSERTIONS SHE WAS NOT WEARING
PREVIOUSLY. JUDGMENTS ARE NO
LONGER FINAL PAST CASES WHICH
REQUIRED CONTINUING LITIGATION
CREATE EVER BURGEONING
CASELOADS SB SEVEN SIX THREE
CONTEMPLATES THAT PROSECUTORS
CHECK THE RECORD OF THE
SENTENCING WHICH REQUIRES THE
ORDERING OF THE SENTENCING
TRANSCRIPT ANOTHER EXPENSE TO
SEE WHETHER THE COURT
CONSIDERED THE CLAIM THAT THE
ORIGINAL SENTENCING F NOT THE
PETITIONER IS ENTITLED TO A
COURT HEARING BEFORE THE
SENTENCING COURT. THIS IN TURN
REQUIRES TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE
COURT TIME PROSECUTION TIME
INDIGENT DEFENSE AND MAY
REQUIRE VICTIM NOTIFICATION
UNDER MARSY'S LAW NORMALLY FOR
A DEFENDANT TO OBTAIN A NEW
SENTENCING MUST MEET THE
STANDARD OF PROOF IN THE HABEAS
PETITION OR ON APPEAL SUCH
PROCEDURES PRESERVE AND RESPECT
THE FINALITY OF JUDGMENTS WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO BETTER INS
IT IS UNCLEAR WHILE WE ARE
SINGLING OUT THIS CLASS OF
DEPENDENTS WHO FAILED TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF AN ISSUE AT
SENTENCING. THIS EXTRAORDINARY
RELIEF IS UNAVAILABLE TO ALL
OTHER DEFENDANTS WHO MIGHT
QUALIFY UNDER OTHER MITIGATION
RULES OR STATUTES FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MORE.
OPPOSITE WITH LEAD WITH.
CORRECT THE BEST AS I'M AWARE
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER MORRIS WE WILL NOW CAN
WITH OUR- THIS IS AN- TO B. AS
SEVEN SIX THREE. WILL MOVE ON
TO. WHAT HE AND WE FORTY OR
THREE. SCENE NINE WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WAS TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN SIX THREE. C. NINE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR NINE THREE I'M SORRY SEVEN
SIXTY WILL BEGIN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAT THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
THERE'S NO ONE Q. OKAY. I'M
SORRY THERE'S ONE PERSON
QUEUING UP. NINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT THE SAME
GUY. PINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND HEARING NOTHING
I'LL CLOSE THE LINE THERE IS NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR FROM ALL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SIX
THREE PLEASE. AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE I'M
SORRY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO OUR-
ONLINE FORTY ONE NOT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M NOT SURE WHAT MINE
FORTY ONE ARE YOU OPEN. I MEAN
ARE YOU THERE. CLOTHING
HEADLINE THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MATTER
MUCH MORE MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THANK
ALL OF OUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS. DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. IT'LL SENATOR
SKINNER. I'M YES- UNDER MEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THE ASSERTION BY THE DA'S THAT
THIS IS LIKE A DOUBLE DIP IN
OTHER WORDS TWO BITES AT THE
APPLE COULD YOU. THANK YOU
SKINNER SKINNER- I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT I RESPECT
THE CDA IS CONCERNS HOWEVER I
POINT OUT THE CURRENT LAW.
ALREADY CONTEMPLATES THIS TYPE
OF PROCESS FOR VETERANS AND
SERVICE MEMBERS WHO WERE
CONVICTED OF A FELONY AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WITH THIS BILL WOULD DO
IS SIMPLY HARMONIZED THAT BY
ALLOWING THOSE CONVICTED PRIOR
TO JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WITH THE SAME PROCESS
SO- I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE THAT THIS IS. NOT THIS
IS NOT UNPRECEDENTED THIS IS
VERY MUCH PRESIDENT AND IS
SIMPLY HARMONIZES THE LAW I'D
ALSO POINT OUT THAT THERE. IS
AS THE SCIENCE IS INCREASING
SHOWING A OFTEN A LAG AND AN
INABILITY FOR SERVICE MEMBERS
AND VETERANS TO BE DIAGNOSED
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS SO IT'S
OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
RAISE THIS ISSUE AT TRIAL-
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE BACKLOG
WITH RECEIVING. MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND DIAGNOSIS SO- I
THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FOR VETERANS I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND AGAIN WHILE I
RESPECT THE DA'S CONCERNS. I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THEM.
BETTER SKINNER- TYPE THE CLEAR
AND- PREHEAT YOUR EXPRESSION
HOWEVER I THINK THAT IT'S
ALWAYS HELPFUL ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE HAVE EXPERT WITNESSES I'M
SORRY IF. NO TICKET THAT THEY
BE ACCURATE IN THEIR TESTIMONY
SO IF BY IN TERMS OF WHEN I
READ THE ANALYSIS AND THEN
YOUR- RESPONSE I WOULD-
ASSERTED THE- DA'S ASSOCIATE
STAFF WERE RATHER ENACT MAYBE
THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY READ THE
BILL- AGAIN FROM THE ANALYSIS
AND- THIS IS WHAT THIS ALLOWS
IS FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE-
SENTENCED. TO JANUARY TWENTY
FIFTEENTH SO I'M NOT SURE WHY
THAT. WHAT HOW THE DA'S
ASSOCIATION COULD ASSERT THAT
THIS IS TWO BITES AT THE APPLE-
SO WITH THAT I MEAN I
PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT. WHAT
WE'VE NOW LEARNED ABOUT TRAUMA
AND A LITTLE TYPE OF TRAUMA
THAT- MANY VETERANS EXPERIENCE.
AND OTHERS IN DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU GROW UP AND- WITNESS GUN
VIOLENCE ON. MULTIPLE TIMES IT
AS A YOUTH THAT TRAUMA IS VERY
COMPARABLE TO THE TYPE OF
TRAUMA THAT A VETERAN
EXPERIENCES IN A COMBAT ZONE.
SO I'VE GIVEN WHAT WE NOW THE
RESEARCH HAS BEEN DONE WHAT WE
NOW KNOW ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THAT TRAUMA I THINK FACTORING
IN THE IMPACTS OF TRAUMA ON
PEOPLE'S SUBSEQUENT BEHAVIOR
ESPECIALLY IF THAT WAS IF THAT
TRAUMA WAS NOT PREVIOUSLY
RECOGNIZED OR TREATED IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF US
PROCEEDING IN PUBLIC SAFETY SO
I APPRECIATE THE BILL AND I
WOULD. MOVE IT. THANK YOU SIR
SKINNER DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE- SB SEVEN
SIX THREE BY SENATOR SKINNER-
SENATOR MAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS SENATOR SKINNER-
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL FOR A
OF A LARGE CLASS OF VETERANS
AND SERVICEMEMBERS WHO SERVED
OUR COUNTRY HONORABLY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR MAN.
MADAM CONSOLE WOULD YOU A CALL
THE ROLL. SB SEVEN SIXTY THREE
DO PASSED TROOPER. BRADFORD A
CHOI BOGUE. I PROVOKE I COME
LONGER I AMAKER AYE. HI SKINNER
I. THREE VOTES FOR THE ROLE. WE
HAVE THREE WILL BE PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL FOR MEMBERS.
THURBER'S. WELCOME SENATOR FOR
TINO I YOU PRESENT SB SEVENTY
AT TIME- YOU WANT TO BE SEVENTY
OR. THREE SEVEN. SORRY THREE
SEVEN FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER SO I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH WILL PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK TO
DEVELOP AN EDUCATIONAL
CURRICULUM SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO PREPARE NEW
OFFICERS TO MEET- THE
PROGRESSING EXPECTATIONS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
NARROW THE BILL TO JUST THE
EDUCATION CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK
FOR SOME HAPPY TO. TAKE THOSE-AMENDMENTS TO TRULY IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY OUTCOMES AND
RESTORE TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE ENTIRETY OF AN OFFICE
REGION REAR. AND TAKE A HOST TO
ME AN ADOPT A HOLISTIC APPROACH
THAT INCLUDES PROVIDING THE
BEST EDUCATION FOR THE
PROFESSION. POLICE WORK IS
ALWAYS BEEN A DANGEROUS JOB
THAT THE CONDITIONS. ARE ALSO
DANGEROUS FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY SURROUNDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THAT. AND SO
EDUCATION AND TRAINING ARE
CRITICAL- THAT IS WHY WE NEED
TO RETHINK OUR APPROACH OF
EDUCATING OFFICERS TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS.
AND SKILLS FOR THE JOB TODAY
TOMORROW AND INTO THE FUTURE.
BUT TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICERS ARE
ALREADY AMONG THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION. WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO LEAD AND RAISE THE BAR IN
TERMS OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
STANDARD THIS IS WHY THE BILL
PROPOSES TO CREATE A NEW
COLLEGE CURRICULUM. TO
SUPPLEMENT THE TRAINING
OFFICERS RECEIVE AT THE
ACADEMY. THE BILL REQUIRE POST
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING
COMMISSION. WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN MAKE COLLEGE
CSU AND THE UC. AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO DEVELOP A LIST
OF COLLEGE COURSES DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND CHALLENGES AND OFFICER
FACES. THESE COURSES MAY BE
TAKEN EITHER PRIOR DURING OR
AFTER COMPLETION OF THE ACADEMY
BUT MUST BE COMPLETED BEFORE AN
INDIVIDUAL CAN CONTAIN- COULD
OBTAIN THEIR BASIC CERTIFICATE.
THIS COURSE WORK WILL FOCUS ON
THE MAIN SUCH A SOCIAL
PSYCHOLOGY MENTAL HEALTH-
AFRICAN AMERICAN RACIAL
HISTORY- COMMUNICATIONS AND
DEBATE SOCIAL. SOCIAL
INEQUALITIES ETHICS CULTURAL
ANTHROPOLOGY. AND MORE. THE
FOCUS THAT YOU PATHWAYS TO.
TRAINING USED INTERNATIONALLY
AND POLICIES WE CAN BUILD UPON
IN THE YEARS TO COME. WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE
WAY IN FORWARD THINKING POLICY
SETTING A NATIONAL PRECEDENT.
AND ATTRACTING ONLY THE BEST
AND BRIGHTEST TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES FRANKLY OUR
COMMUNITIES DEMAND THAT WE DO
THAT. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
ADVANCE OUR SHARED GOALS IN
ELEVATING THE PROFESSION. ON
THE PHONE TODAY I HAVE BRIAN-
MARBLE THE PRESIDENT OF PORAC
AND ERIC NUNEZ THE PRESIDENT OF
THE C. PCA- AND WE ALSO HAVE-
JONATHON FELDMAN ON THE LINE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IF ANY
QUESTIONS ARISE. THANK YOU. WE
GOTTA GO THE LEAD WITNESSES. OR.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I'M SORRY.
RELATED TO DO I GOT HERE
DELETED. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
OF THE- SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TODAY SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN A
LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK FOR
EDUCATING CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
GENERATION OF PEACE OFFICERS MY
NAME IS BRIAN MARBLE AND I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
OR POOR IRAQ. IN ORDER FOR US
TO HAVE THE BEST TRAINED AND
MOST HIGHLY EDUCATED PEACE
OFFICERS IN THE COUNTRY BY THE
END OF THIS DECADE. WE MUST DO
MORE TO PROVIDE OUR OFFICERS
WITH THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THEY NEED TO
PREPARE FOR THE CHALLENGES OF
MODERN DAY POLICING. THE BASIC
DUTIES OF A PEACE OFFICER HAVE
CHANGED IMMENSELY OVER THE
YEARS. BUT THE LEVEL OF
EDUCATION WE EXPECT OUR
OFFICERS TO PREPARE THEM FOR
THE ADVERSITIES THEY WILL FACE
ON THE JOB TODAY. HAS CHANGED
VERY LITTLE. TODAY LINE
OFFICERS AND LEADERS MUST BE
ABLE TO MEET A VARIETY OF
CHALLENGES INCLUDING
HOMELESSNESS. DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ABUSE HATE CRIMES AND A GROWING
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. JEFFREY
FAGAN A CRIMINOLOGIST AT
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY MAY HAVE
SAID IT BEST WE WANT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR EMOTIONAL
REGULATION WE WANT PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOOD AT PLANNING AND
THINKING AHEAD. WE WANT PEOPLE
TO HAVE A CAPACITY TO LEARN
FROM THEIR MISTAKES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT BASIC
POLICE ACADEMY SIMPLY DOESN'T
HAVE ENOUGH HOURS TO COVER
EVERYTHING WE WANT OUR NEXT
GENERATION PEACE OFFICERS TO
KNOW. SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
WOULD CREATE A NEW CURRICULUM
TO AUGMENT THE TRAINING
OFFICERS RECEIVE AT THE
ACADEMY. THIS CURRICULUM WOULD
BE DEVELOPED IN PHASES OVER
TIME IT WOULD INCLUDE ACADEMIC
COURSE WORK ON MENTAL HEALTH
SOCIAL SERVICES PSYCHOLOGY
COMMUNICATIONS AND MORE. THE
GOAL IS TO EVENTUALLY CREATED
AGREE SPECIFIC TO THE PRACTICE
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
REQUIRES A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
TO QUALIFY FOR A CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IT MUST REMAIN
THAT WAY. THIS ALLOWS FOR A
MUCH LARGER CANADA POOL. SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES INTERESTED IN A
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
FURTHER BOTH THEIR ACADEMIC AND
CAREER GOALS WHILE PREPARING TO
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES AS PEACE
OFFICERS. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR PROVIDING ME
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER
POOR ACT PROFESSIONAL KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERTISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN OTHER TOWARDS OUR
GOALS OF HAVING THE BEST AND
MOST HIGHLY EDUCATED POLICE
FORCE IN THE COUNTRY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. WITNESS YES-
MEMBERS WENT. MY NAME IS ERIC
UNIONS AND I'M IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE ASSOCIATE
PLEASE SHE'S SUFFICIENT. HAVING
SAT DOWN FOR THAT THERE'S- JUST
WEEK THANK YOU FOR THE- TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN AS INCREDIBLE
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. NCPC A IS PROUD TO
BE A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. SB
THREE SEVEN WILL SET IN MOTION
THE DEVELOPMENT OF EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAY FOR CALIFORNIA LW
ENFORCEMENT THAT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY. TRANSFORM
POLICING IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
ENGINE THE CHANGE IN OUTCOMES
AT EVERY SINGLE ACTING THAT.
LEAVING THE ACADEMY HAD A
COMPLETE CALL COURSEWORK IN
PSYCHOLOGY SOCIOLOGY PHILOSOPHY
HISTORY ANATOMY AND YOU NAME
IT. HOW BETTER EQUIPPED TO OUR
OFFICERS BE IT BEFORE THE WHERE
THE BATCH THEY'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
CURRICULUM THAT INCLUDES
INTERNSHIPS IN FIELDS RELATED
TO BUT OUTSIDE OF POLICING AND
A MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC OR
SOCIAL SERVICE CENTER. CRITICAL
THINKING AND EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE ARE KEY TRAITSWE
NEED DEVELOP IN OUR OFFICERS.
EDUCATE THE EDUCATIONAL PATHWAY
CREATED BY S. SPEECH REDUCE.
WHICH WILL BE. WITH COURAGE CAN
LEADER AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TOGETHER WILL ENSURE THOSE
TRADES ARE ENHANCED AND EVERY.
PERSPECTIVE OFFICER. I'M
EXCITED TO SEE THIS BILL BECOME
REALITY AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
WORKING YET. AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
NOW WILL GO TO WITNESSES INSIDE
OF THE FORTY TWO ALL THREE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES SWITCHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SEEN NINE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM OF
TWENTY FORTY. SEEN NO ONE.
MODERATOR WOULD NOW GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN. AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE TO A BY PRESSING ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
GO TIMELINE NINETY TWO ONE
MOMENT. AND NINETY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING IT'S AARON
READ REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
BE A CO SPONSORING THIS BILL
WITH BOTH PORAC AND THE POLICE
CHIEFS- AS OUTLINED BY THE
AUTHOR AND THE TWO WITNESSES
BEFORE ME IT'S A HUGE
MONUMENTAL. MOVEMENT IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE L. EIGHT. AND
ONE MOMENT. ONE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HM MEMBERS RANGE
FROM MOLECULAR SUCH J. SHOWN
ALL BE OUT OFFICER BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
US. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO ONE
SET. NINE ONE THREE YEAR LINE
TO GO. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS SHALL MUCH THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE THE.
FOURTEEN BACKWARDNESS.
AND I'M SORRY THERE ARE NO
LONGER IN Q. I WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY FOUR. BY FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBER SHAUN
RUNDLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN POINT. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT. WE GOT A LINE. SEVENTY
SEVEN. ONE MOMENT. SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
SIR GOOD MORNING JOHN LEVEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THESE GOOD
SENSE BILL. THANK YOU. WE KNOW
OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ARE DOES SHE JUST
ALONG ONE MORE TIME FOR
WOULDN'T AND. AND ONCE AGAIN
PRESS ONE SEVEN ZERO IF YOU'RE
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME I'M
SHOWING A LINE THING Q. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I SEE WE
HAVE A PRIMARY WERE AFTER THE
LOOKING THE CLOCK HOURS OR
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO BE
DANNECKER. WROTE A MAIL IF TO
DECORATE. IN OPPOSITION. YOU
HAVE ME YES BUT I THINK ALSO I
SHARON IS HERE AS WELL OKAY
HELLO MMHM I'LL LET YOU GUYS
DECIDE TO START WITH FIVE TOTAL
SO WHICH JOURNAL- DONNA ROW
AMOUNT YOU MAY BEGIN. ALL START
BOBBY GREENE- AND- I'M ACARA DI
MOUNT ST POLICY DIRECT THE DAMP
THAT GOT DEFENDER AND I SANDERS
WELL TO WORKING ON THE- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
CHANGE AS I DID SO WANT THAT TO
THEM. OVER SB THREE EIGHTY I
THE BUILD OUT OF STEP TO MOVE
FOR A JEFF AND COMMUNITY FORTIN
SHARE DURING A WHEN NATION
PEOPLE ARE PUSHING FOR A
REIMAGINING OF STATE AND YOU
FIND THE QUALITY. KNOW THAT ALL
BUT THIS COME CAN THE EXACT
NUMBER A JURY IT CAN WHAT OR
NOT CAN MAKE THE. EIGHT THREE
EIGHT IS THAT WE DON'T NEED
MORE OFFICERS ARE JUST BETTER
TRAINED OFFICERS WE NEED A
DRAMATIC OVERHAUL OF THE
STRUCTURE OF OUR SOCIETY IN THE
SYSTEM TO RELY ON FOR STATE THE
INJECTIONS WE NEED MORE
INVESTMENT AND SERVICES AND
SUPPORT IN COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCING HIGH LEVELS OF
POVERTY AND VIOLENCE WE NEED
MORE ON ARM CARE GIVERS DEEPLY
TRAINED IN DE ESCALATION
STRATEGIES. INTENDED THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES DRIVING
DRUG ADDICTION OR ANOTHER
DRESSED TREMONT OFTEN SIMPLY
NEED SOMEONE TO SHOW THEM AN
ACT OF KINDNESS AND RECOGNIZE
THEIR HUMANITY NOT MORE OFTEN
THIRD TO IN MOMENTS OF
HEIGHTENED ANXIETY CAN'T TELL
THE DIFFERENCE. BETWEEN THE GUN
AND THEIR CASE THERE. WE NEED
TO INVEST IN A NEW WORLD NOT
CONTINUE REACHED INTO. AND
CULTURE THAT HAVE TIME AND
AGAIN BE BROKE AT. THE BOTTOM
DEREK ADDITIONAL PUBLIC FUNDS
TO PROMOTE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RECRUITMENT AND EDUCATION THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD DO WELL TO
LISTEN THE COMMUNITY IS. ASKING
TO DIVEST MON FORCE MEANT AND
INVEST IN COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CLASS. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. OKAY OF THE
MORNING ARE THERE A NUMBER. MY
NAME IS JEREMY MARTIN AND I AM
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER OR HE'LL
COME BACK. JOHN PHYSICIAN OF
THE SEVEN. WELL HAVE CAUGHT THE
OFFICE WILL NOTHING A NUMBER
BECAUSE CONCERNS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CAN HIGH MINE ARE THE
STATE LEGISLATOR COULD AT BEST
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESCO
COMMITTEE. SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN PROPOSES TO DO THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE
DRIVEN BY THE COMMUNITY. THOSE
CLOSEST TO THE PROBLEM ARE THE
ONES WHO HAVE THE SOLUTION SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN IS OUT. OF
TOUCH WITH THE CURRENT NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE PEOPLE THE
POLICE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING. THE BALLOT BUT IF THE
COURT TO INCLUDE A REQUIREMENTS
FOR OBTAINING A BASICALLY
PERFECT. SB THREE SEVEN TO.
STATE FARM. WE TAKE ISSUE WITH
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC FUNDS WHEN A
LACK OF EDUCATION IS NOT THE
ISSUE. ADDITIONAL AND- OR
SPECIFIC COURSES FOR CHANGE FOR
CORRECT THE CULTURE OF VIOLENCE
THE POLICING. FURTHERMORE WHILE
WITH OFF THE RIGHT POST TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS THE BILL
FAILS FIND NECESSARY DETAILED
IMPLEMENTATION BUT JUST HOW THE
STAKEHOLDERS WOULD BE SELECTED.
THE BILL FAILS TO EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
THOSE KILLED BY POLICE VIOLENCE
STAKEHOLDERS. WHILE THE
STAKEHOLDERS CAN INCLUDE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS DO NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDE IMPACT THE
FAMILY MEMBER. SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN X. FOR FUNDING FOR
PROGRAM THAT WILL NOT THIRTY
HE'LL THE COMMUNITY IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE INVEST IN
COMMITTEE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
ARE CHILDREN VICTIMIZED BY
POLICE VIOLENCE. THAT IS
DIRECTLY PROVIDING EQUAL ACCESS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH. PROVIDE
SCHOOL TEACHERS AND COUNSELORS
WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
RECOGNIZE SIGNS OF TRAUMA. AND
PTSD IN CHILDREN. BLACKLISTING
THE MARC B. OVERLY BECAUSE- SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN AT THE RUN
BACK WITHOUT ANY. GRAMMAR I
THANK OVER YOUR YOUR YOUR VOICE
OPEN YOUR MIGHT. TO UNDERSTAND
I MEAN AND OVER HERE I AGREE
THAT THE POLICE VIOLENCE. DO
NOT JUST SEE IT DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
THAT YOU DO NOT SUPPORT. SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NUMBER TO WITNESS
HERE IN FORTY TWO OLD THREE
HIGH SHE NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF ARMENIAN OPPOSITION
I'M SORRY OF S. B. THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN AND HERE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THEIR MODERATOR
WILL GO NOW TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE. EIGHT SEVEN. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT. I WILL
GO. A LINE. ONE FIFTEEN AND ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
HI GOOD MORNING- THIS IS LOOSE
WIRES WERE CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
PANEL. THANK YOU. YOU WITNESS.
JOIN OTHER WITNESSES AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
AND I'M SHOWING NO OTHERS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME. I
THINK WE MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER
TAKER. MODERATOR X. SHARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SORRY I WAS ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE- OPPOSITION
WITNESSES BUT I YELLED AT MY
TIME TO SHARING- THIS IS KAELIN
DEAN LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE A
CELL YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
EIGHT SEVEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN Q.
WANTED TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. OPERATOR.
ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE IN TEN ZERO
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION. AND
ALLOW IN A FEW MOMENTS I'M
GOING NO ACTORS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ON AN
INTERESTED TIME WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO. SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR TROUBLED. PURCELL
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS MATTER
FORWARD I AM AT- AS A FORMER
TEACHER I AM ALWAYS AN ADVOCATE
FOR EDUCATION AND MORPORK
PREPARATION AND- I HAVE OFTEN
HEARD. THE HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO ONE RECRUIT A QUALITY
CANDIDATES TO WORK IN AND-
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THIS TO ME
JUST GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
ADD TO THE QUALITY AS WELL AS
TO- REALLY IMPROVE AND EXPAND
THE EDUCATION- ON THAT ENDEAVOR
SO THANK OU SO MUCH I AM
EXCITED TO SEE HOW- THE BILL
PROCEED AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING IT AS AN EVIL. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTERS CARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS BUT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD
A- BILL THAT HELPS TO- ENHANCE
THE TRAINING AND EDUCATION OF
OUR- SWORN OFFICERS- BY. YOUR
COMMENTS IN YOUR OPENING ABOUT
THE RISK THAT ARE SWORN
OFFICERS TAKE EVERY DAY THEY
WALK OUT THE DOOR IN THEIR
UNIFORMS OR IS IT IS- IS
ABSOLUTELY ACCURATE. AND D. I
THINK THE- AUSSIE TRAUMA IT'S A
VERY COMMON WORD IN THIS
COMMITTEE BUT I THINK THE
TRAUMA THAT. WE AND I SAY A
COLLECTIVE WEEK OUR-
COMMUNITIES WHO UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO MORE
POLICE VIOLENCE BUT ALSO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. WHO
THEMSELVES ARE. IT WHO IN
VARIOUS ENCOUNTERS WHETHER IT'S-
CIRCUMSTANCES IN AS A. FIVE
WHETHER TO TRAFFIC STOP FOR ANY
NUMBER OF THINGS WHERE WHERE AN
ARMED PERSON CAN ALSO DO HARM
TO THE OFFICERS THAT THIS. THAT
THESE. THIS VERY- IT'S ALMOST I
I'M NOT SURE WHAT WORD TO USE
BUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
INTENSE AND THEY OFTEN THEY CAN
LEAD TO. NOT GOOD DECISIONS AND
I THINK THE S. B. PRESIDENT
PORAC MENTION OR MAYBE IT WAS
ANOTHER WITNESS. BETTER
TRAINING AND MORE EDUCATION
WELL IT WOULD NOT ELIMINATE.
MUCH AS SOME OF THE REACTIONS
THAT OCCUR. IT COULD GREATLY
IMPROVE THEM. AND WE I THINK WE
HAVE AIRED IN THAT. GIVEN THAT
WE PUT THIS IS ONE OF THE ONLY
JOBS THAT IN PUBLIC SERVICE
WERE BASICALLY WE ALLOW. BY
BEING ARMED IN FACT. AND I
DON'T MEAN TO SAY THIS LIGHTLY
WE ALLOW SWORN OFFICERS TO TAKE
SOMEONE'S LIFE. THAT TO HAVE
THE KIND OF MINIMAL EDUCATION
AND TRAINING THAT WE HAVE THUS
FAR AND THIS AND I DON'T WANT
TO SWORN OFFICERS TO THINK THAT
I FEEL THAT YOU HAVE NO
TRAINING NO BUT THE- BUT GIVEN
THE GRAVITY. OF YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO IMPROVE THAT
TRAINING AND EDUCATION AND I
THINK THAT'S- THE PURPOSE OF
YOUR BILL AND WE ALSO. AND I
THINK THE INTENTION WHICH IS
NOW BEEN SOMEWHAT MODIFIED.
AROUND TURNER ENHANCE OUR
ABILITY TO RECRUIT. BUT THE
VERY ATTRACTION TO THE
POSITION. MAY IN BY THESE
CHANGES. IT MAY AND IT MAY
CHANGE TO THAT IS ATTRACTED TO
THE POSITION ALSO SO WE COULD
BE- ASSISTING THAT OTHER GOAL
JUST BY. THE CHANGE IN OUR
TRAINING AND EDUCATION THAT
YOUR BILL. IS RECOMMENDING SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND- I WILL MOVE IT.
UNLESS IT'S ALREADY BEEN MOVED
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE IT. I DON'T
KNOW IF THE SENATOR- TO ABOVE
DID- AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FOR. THANK YOU CENTER CONNOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM TO
AM VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU
ACCEPTED- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. YOU KNOW I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ON GOING
AND CAN CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSIONS- AROUND SORT OF
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT PUBLIC
SAFETY. IS ABOUT- AND
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT THE
RELATIONSHIP SHOULD BE BETWEEN
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT-
AND I THINK IT IS- IT WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE TO KIND OF PLACE
THOSE- REALLY- CIRCUMSPECT OF
DISCUSSIONS TO WAIT THIS BILL
DOWN WITH- WITH THOSE VERY
HEAVY- IN DEEP YOU KNOW ISSUES-
NO BILL IS ABOUT YOU KNOW.
ENCOMPASSES THE TOTALITY OF
ISSUE THAT WE'RE FACING. I SAY
THAT IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE SHARED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I AM. I
AM GLAD THAT THE- RECRUITMENT
ASPECT OF THE BILL AS IT
RELATES TO GOING INTO THE
SCHOOLS WAS MODIFIED- THEN I
WON'T GET INTO THAT. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE- TO THE LEFT OF ME-
SHARED. YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY THE
REALITY IS THAT WE GIVE
UNFETTERED AUTHORITY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT- INTO POLICE
OFFICERS FOLKS GET A BADGE THEY
GET A GUN WE SEND THEM OUT INTO
THE WORLD. AND WE ASK THEM TO
BE SUPERMAN AND SUPER WOMEN-
AND WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
DIAL THAT BACK. AND OFFER MORE
OF A LOT OF THINGS- TO HELP
THEM STAY SAFE. TO HELP THEM
MANAGE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH- AND
TO ALSO HELP THEM MANAGE THE
KINDS OF DECISIONS THAT WE ARE
ASKING THEM TO MAKE SECOND BY
SECOND MINUTE BY MINUTE. WHILE
THEY'RE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FOLKS WHO THEY ARE
SERVING ARE ALSO PROTECTED AND
ARE SAFE- I HOPE THAT THERE CAN
BE DEEPER DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
KINDS OF TRAINING THAT OUR
OFFICERS NEED- THE KINDS OF
EDUCATION THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE. AND WHAT THE DECISIONS
THAT THEY ARE BEING ASKED TO
MAKE HOW THOSE DECISIONS IMPACT
NOT JUST THE INDIVIDUAL OR THE
INDIVIDUAL'S THAT THEY MAY BE
CONFRONTING. BUT THE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND THE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ALSO IMPACTED EVERY SINGLE DAY
BY THE DECISIONS THAT THEY
MAKE. AND WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
WAY TO EMPOWER FOLKS WITH
EDUCATION AND INFORMATION. TO
NOT JUST GO TO THE LOWEST
COMMON DENOMINATOR WHEN IT
COMES TO CRISIS RESOLUTION AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE BEING
CONFRONTED WITH NOW IN CURRENT
TIMES- AS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY SO. I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT AND- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE- WITH
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WARNER I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
I TOO WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THAT
AMENDMENTS AS I THINK OUR
EXPRESS PREVIOUSLY. THE HEART
OF THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND I
REALLY THINK IT'S GREAT TO
FOCUS THE BILL ON THAT BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK THIS BILL TAKES AN
INCREDIBLY THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
TO THOSE AND A FLEXIBLE
APPROACH TO THOSE EDUCATION.
REQUIREMENTS SO I THINK IT'S A
POSITIVE THING I HAVE FOR MANY
MANY MANY YEARS AS A-
NEIGHBORHOOD LEADER BEFORE I
WAS IN PUBLIC OFFICE AS A LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIAL- AND MY JOB IS
ATTORNEY INTERACTED WITH A LOT
OF POLICE OFFICERS OVER THE
YEARS. AND THERE'S A HUGE
SPECTRUM OF OFFICES IN TERMS OF
PERSONALITY TYPES- BUT ALSO
JUST SKILL SETS AND INTERACTING
WITH THE PUBLIC IN A WAY THAT
DOES NOT LEAD. TO USE OF FORCE
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
PLENTY OF POLICE OFFICERS WHO
ARE VERY SKILLED WHO NEVER FIRE
THEIR- GUN THEIR ENTIRE CAREER
THERE I THINK IT'S A VAST
MAJORITY AND I THINK SOMETHING
LIKE A MAJORITY OF OFFICERS
NEVER EVEN DRAW. THEIR PISTOL
IN THEIR ENTIRE CAREER- AND SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF OFFICERS WHO
I THINK ARE YOU KNOW. OUR OUR
HAVE THOSE SKILLS BUT WE NEED
TO BE ALL OFFICERS WANT TO BE A
HUNDRED PERCENT- AND I THINK
THIS BILL WILL THERE'S NO
SILVER BULLET BUT THIS BILL
WILL HELP MOVE US IN THAT
DIRECTION- AND SO I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE. THE BILL THERE HASN'T
BEEN A MOTION ALREADY. THANK
YOU. AND I WANT TO THANK OF MY
CALL. FOR MAKING THEIR COMMENTS
ON THIS MEASURE AND I TOO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
WORKING NOT ONLY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE WILL WITH ME TO MOVE
FORWARD AND BRINGING FORTH THE
MEASURE THAT WE CAN ALL
SUPPORT. AND I THINK IT WOULD
BE NO ARGUMENT THAT A BETTER
TRAINED OFFICER IS A- MAKES OUR
COMMUNITY SAFER. BUT I THINK WE
ALL HAVE TO AGREE THAT TRAINING
IN AND OF ITSELF IS NOT ENOUGH.
WE'VE SEEN TOO FAR TOO MANY
INCIDENTS WHERE THEY GET IT
RIGHT IN WHITE NEIGHBORHOODS.
BUT THEY DON'T GET A RIDE IN
BLACK AND BROWN NEIGHBORHOODS
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY KNOW WHEN
THE DRAW THEIR WEAPON. IN A
FLUID NEIGHBORHOODS AND- THE
SAME THING THAT. CONFRONTS THEM
IN A BLACK NEIGHBORHOOD MAKE
SOME FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES AND-
IT GOES TO RECRUITMENT AS WELL.
AND THAT WAS FBI STUDY ABOUT
FOUR YEARS AGO THE STATE IT.
THE LARGEST RECRUITMENT OF
WHITE SUPREMACIST. INDIVIDUALS
ARE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT RIGHT
NOW THAT SHOULD BE TROUBLING TO
ALL OF US WHETHER YOU'RE A
MINORITY WHETHER YOU'RE WHITE
THIS SHOULD BE A CONCERN TO ALL
OF US SO RECRUITMENT IS. TRUE
TRULY A MAJOR PART OF THIS. AND
CHANGING THE I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN CHANGE SOMEONE'S HEART.
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE
IS PREJUDICE. THERE IS HATRED
AND I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
TRAINING WORLD IT'S GONNA.
REMOVE THAT BECAUSE FOR SOME
FOLKS IT'S A GREAT FEAR OF
ANYONE WITH MELANIN IN THEIR
SKIN TONE. AND I WILL ONLY USE
EXAMPLE OF JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO WHEN A WHITE INDIVIDUAL
WENT INTO A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
JUST NORTH OF HERE. CLEARLY
STATED HE WANTED TO KILL
OFFICERS. CLEARLY STATED HE WAS
THERE TO KILL OFFICERS EVEN
TOOK AN OFFICER'S BRIAN HEAD
CAME IN WITH A GUN FOR SELF I
SHOULD SAY AND THAT INDIVIDUAL
SOMEHOW MADE IT OUT ALIVE WAS
ABLE TO POST BAIL AND- WAS ABLE
TO. SPEND TIME WITH HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS. WHERE IS IN THIS STATE
AND IN IN THIS COUNTRY IF
YOU'RE BLACK AND YOU'RE BROWN
AND YOU'RE RUNNING FROM POLICE
OFFICERS YOU FIND YOURSELF MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT SHOT AND KILLED.
AND EVADING ARREST SHOULD NOT
BE A DEATH SENTENCE RUNNING
FROM A POLICE OFFICER SHOULD
NOT BE A DEATH SENTENCE AND
THAT'S THE TROUBLING PART WITH
ME'S AND A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING SO I THINK- AGAIN
AUTHORED FOR UNDERSTANDING THAT
AND HAS EXPRESSED HIS CONCERN.
HAVING NOT ONLY A BETTER
TRAINING OFFICER BUT A BETTER
DIVERSE POLICE DEPARTMENT THE
REFLECTS ALL COMMUNITIES ALL
GENDERS. THAT TRULY HAS O BE A
PART OF THIS. EQUATION A MORE
COMPASSIONATE OFFICER. AND A
GREATER REVERENCE FOR LIFE OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU TRAIN AT BUT I
BELIEVE YOU CAN RECRUIT THAT.
SOUL I KNOW IT'S NOT ALL WHAT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO PUT IT TO A
GREAT START TO FIXING A
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM THAT HAS
EXISTED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. FOR
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS AND WE
HAVE TO DO BETTER- WE DO HAVE
TO REIMAGINE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND I THINK THIS BILL HELPS US
DO THAT SO ON THAT NOTE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER I
WOULD FORGET THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO SIGN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES. I THINK YOUR.
COMMENT WE HAVE TO DO BETTER IS
REALLY. IS REALLY THE DIRECTION
WE ALL HAVE TO TAKE- WE JUST
HAVE TO DO BETTER AND I BELIEVE
THIS BILL TAKES A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS- THE PROGRAMS
AND ISSUES RAISED HER. FROM THE
OPPOSITION. NO ONE TAKES
LIGHTLY- CERTAINLY WE NEED TO
FIND- MANY OF THE EFFORTS THAT
ARE ONGOING. AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO YOUR SECOND ITEM. S.
B. SEVEN ONE FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- SENDING SB
SEVEN FIFTEEN WHICH REQUIRED
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
VERIFY THE VALIDITY OF THE
HUNT. OF A- PERSON UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE HAS A LICENSE
TO HAS HUNTING LICENSE IN ORDER
TO PURCHASE A FIREARM FIREARMS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN
TRANSFERRING OR PURCHASING A
FIREARM WITHIN HOT. WITH A
HUNTING LICENSE THERE'S NO
VERIFICATION PROCESS DURING THE
TEN DAY BACKGROUND CHECK. TO
ENSURE THAT THE LICENSE IS
VALID IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
IN NINETEEN YEAR OLD ILLEGALLY
PURCHASED THE SEMI ARCTIC
CENTERFIRE RIFLE FROM A DEALER.
WITH AN INVALID HUNTING LICENSE
AND TRAGICALLY OPENED FIRE AT A
SYNAGOGUE IN POWAY. BECAUSE THE
GUN STORE FAILED TO ADEQUATELY
CHECK THE VALIDITY OF THE
LICENSE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CLEAR THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS. THAT HORRIFIC TRAGEDY
OCCURRED THIS BALL ALSO DEALS
WITH AN UNRESOLVED ISSUE IN A
PREVIOUS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
SPECIFICALLY THIS CLARIFIES
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
INVESTIGATE AN OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING THAT RESULTED IN THE
DEATH OF AN UNARMED CIVILIAN.
OR IF THERE IS A REASONABLE
DISPUTE THAT THIS IS A CIVILIAN
WAS ON ARM THIS IS OF
PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE TO ME.
BECAUSE- IN PASADENA. LAST YEAR
THERE IS A DISPUTE ABOUT
SOMEONE WHO WAS TRAGICALLY SHOT
OF WHETHER THAT PERSON HAD A
GUN. OR DIDN'T HAVE A GUN AND
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE UNDER THE
PRIOR LAW WOULD NOT ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE. AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE ISSUES WERE TRYING TO CLEAR
OUT IF IT IF IT'S DISPUTED THE
AG SHOULD BE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE. LASTLY THE BILL
CONTAINS CODE CLEANUP AND
REFERENCES. ULTIMATELY SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN WILL ADDRESS
OUTSTANDING CIRCUMSTANCES I'M
COVERED IN THE POWAY SHOOTING
ENSURE THAT BACKGROUND CHECKS
ARE DONE COMPREHENSIVELY SO
THAT THE SAME MISTAKES DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN. AND OBVIOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I KNOW- YOU ALL BEEN
WANTING IRWIN- NETWORK TO MAKE
HIS RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE. HE
IS HERE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SO WE ALSO
BROUGHT BACK A WIN FOR YOU ALL.
I THOUGHT. NO I DON'T HAVE A
CARD- HA HA HA HA. ONLY IF THEY
HAVE A QUESTION OR WITH OKAY.
SO AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN FIFTEEN- HAVING
SAID THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
BROOME. FORTY TWO OH THREE DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIFTEEN
SEEN NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIFTEEN.
SEEN NONE. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PRINT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN FIFTEEN WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU A PRIEST
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOUR IN SUPPORT. THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU MODERATE
IF YOU WILL. WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT AND GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
THERE IS A. ONE WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY FIVE. AND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THIS TIME I'M
SHOWING NO OTHER COLORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD CHECK
THE LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM- ALL OF OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR SB SEVEN FIFTEEN
POINT. AND ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO. IF YOU WANT TO.
VOICE YOUR SUPPORT. ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND ALLOW A FEW
MOMENTS I AM SHOWING NO LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
I'M HAVING HEARD FROM ALL OUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR S. B.
SEVEN FIFTEEN WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ARE ACTUALLY. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY BUT WE DO HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- SEMPRA RATE
IS OUR LEAD OPPOSITION WITH GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA DO WE HAVE
MR PERATIS' ON THE LINE. I AM
HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
ABSOLUTELY MISTER PRESS PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
IS AN INTERNIST CALIFORNIA AN
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED BY- NOW
YOU SEE STAND AND FORMER UNITED
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR RACHEL
RICHARDSON. IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. THIRTEEN H. BASICALLY A
REINTRODUCTION OF SB NINE
THIRTEEN OF TWENTY TWENTY WHICH
WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR SUMMONED
GOC BELIEVES THE GOVERNOR'S
OBJECTIONS TO THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN ISSUE. WITH
SB SEVEN FIFTEEN INDUSTRY TO
MESSAGE GOVERNOR WROTE. I AM
RETURNING SENATE BILL MIND
COURTROOM WITHOUT MY SIGNATURE
THIS BILL WOULD BEGINNING JULY
MORE BEGINNING JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO VERIFY
THE VALIDITY OF HUNTING
LICENCES WITH A DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE FOR A SALE OR
TRANSFER OF A FIREARM TO A
PERSON UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE. YOU'LL GET IT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY
TO VERIFY THE VALIDITY OF
HUNTING LICENCES IN ORDER TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL IT WILL TAKE DOT THIRTY
MONTHS TO COMPLETE THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
DURING THIS TIME THEY WOULD
HAVE TO REDIRECT EXISTING
APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES WHICH COULD AFFECT
THE WORK CURRENTLY SCHEDULED
FOR SEVEN PREVIOUSLY ENACTED
BILLS IMPACTING. FARMS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
I'M RETURNING THAT- CONCERNED.
THAT ADDING ADDITIONAL
TECHNOLOGY. HOLDEN PD OKAY. ON
THE WAY IT ALREADY HAS BEEN.
ALL THE GOVERNOR RACES BALLOT
CONCERNS MEDIUM OR A- EXTENDS
TO OTHER OF. LOCATIONS OF THE
BILL PUTS THERE'S NO NEED TO
ADDRESS. THE OF HUNTING LICENSE
ALSO THE LANGUAGE REGARDING
ISSUE OF LONG. FIERY TO MINORS
IS OVERLY. AND BURDENSOME AND
UNNECESSARY AND THAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE PRESENCE OF PARENTS
OF ALL SHOOTING EVENTS EVEN
WHEN THERE IS AN ABUNDANCE OF
ADULT SUPERVISION SUCH A
RESTRICTION ON FAIRLY
UNNECESSARILY PENALIZES. MANY
LAW ABIDING YOU IN OUR COUNTRY
CORNING GAUGE THEM LOOKED
PLEDGING THAT SHOOTING SPORTS
WEATHER IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE YOU SHOULDN'T CLOSE
EXISTING DEVELOP GROW AND
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT. OF
THIS FIRING DEDICATED JUNIOR
ATHLETES WHO COULD SOMEDAY
REPRESENT UNITED STATES IN
COMPETITIONS WHETHER IT'S THE
OLYMPIC GAMES PAN AMERICAN
GAMES WORLD SHOOTING
CHAMPIONSHIPS. AND OLYMPIC
GAMES OR OTHER INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITIONS FINALLY DONE MOST
EGREGIOUSLY S. B. THIRTEEN.
ALLOWS FOR THE RAISING OF THE
COST OF AMMUNITION PARTS
ACQUISITION AGAIN FINANCIALLY
PENALIZING THE LAW BY THE IN
ORDER TO COMBAT THE EFFECTS
BROUGHT ON BY THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT IN OUR SOCIETY. WILL
HAVE NO BEARING ON WHICH WILL
HAVE NO BEARING ON GUN VIOLENCE
ORGANIZATION AS A FORTY YEAR
HISTORY OF FIGHTING CORPORATE
CRIME CONTROL AND OPPOSING
INEFFECTIVE GUN CONTROL.
SPECIFIC TO CALIFORNIANS THE
VERY FOUNDATION OF OUR MISSION
AND IT HAS BEEN A CONSISTENT
GOAL TO WORK TOWARD COMMONSENSE
SOLUTION REGARDING. USES OF
CRIME EMPIRE MOTOR SHIPS THIS
CAN BE DONE HOWEVER WITHOUT
SACRIFICING OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AND THE ABILITY OF A LOT
ABOUT EACH PROTECT ABOUT NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSE SB SEVEN
FIFTY THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
PERATIS' FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND
LEAD OPPOSITION WHAT DOES
MISTER ROY GRIFFITH. IS MISTER
ROY GRIFFITH ON THE LINE. HE M.
GOOD MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS
REUTER REPRESENTING THE CAL
RIGHT AND PISTOL. OUR MEMBERS
ARE HELD STRONG OPPOSITE TO
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
ONE FIVE STARTED OUT LAST YEAR
THE BILL TO CLEAR WOULDN'T
HUNTING LICENSE AGENTS OR OF A
FIREARM AFTER MULTIPLE WOMEN
THE BILL FROM NEW FAXES THAT
UNNECESSARILY RESTRICTED AND
ACCESS TRANSFER OF FAR IN FOR
PARK BY LAW BY CITIZEN DO WE
REALLY NEED A PIECE LEGISLATION
TO WHAT ABOUT ANYWAY. TOTAL TO
DATE PRINTED ON THE LICENSE DO
THAT I WAS A GAME WARDEN FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I LITERALLY
CHECKED THOUSANDS OF HUNTING
LICENCES AND NEVER NEEDED A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION OR
ANYTHING IS CONVOLUTED TO
CONFIRM YEAH I MEAN LICENSE WAS
A BALLERINA ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL ATTEMPTS TO CLARIFYING
TRANSFERS ON USING THEIR
CULTURE BECAUSE THE
CLARIFICATION IS JUST SUCH A
CONVOLUTED MESS THAT ANY LAW
ABIDING LAWFUL GUN ORDER CAN
UNDERSTAND IT REGULATIONS DO.
NOT NEED TO BE THIS COMPLICATED.
YOU MIGHT CALL A HAS OR COVERED
CONCERN WITH FEES RELATE TO
THIS ONE. PRE PEAK TELLS.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY. PLACES I
KNOW. RESPONSE ON THE- JUSTICE
ROY WE STILL OVER TEN THOUSAND.
QALINGE ON OUR STREETS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE KNOW WHAT
WE HAD TO GET A MORE ACCURATE
UPDATED NUMBER FROM DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. WE CAN AND SHOULD
GET THESE INDIVIDUALS OFF OUR
STREETS AND WE DO NOT NEED TO
PUT THE BUILDING OF ANOTHER
MACHINE LIKE THIS ON THE BACK
OF DOJ JUST TO KEEP. TRACK A
SMALL HANDFUL OF INDIVIDUALS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD WHO
ATTEMPT TO LAWFULLY PURCHASED
FIREARMS. I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS VERY
UNNECESSARY LEGISLATION. LET'S
SAY THE GOVERNOR HAPPEN TO VETO
IT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME IN THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU OUR MOVED TO OUR WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM AND OPPOSITION. TWO
SB SEVEN ONE FIVE SEEN ON HERE
NOW LET'S MOVE TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THE MODERATOR LET'S
MOVE TO OUR PHONE LINES DO WE
HAVE CALLERS IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION AS P. SEVEN ONE FIVE.
AND FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NOW AND THEN THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. ONE OF THEM THEY'RE
ALL. TO BE JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
BLIND ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE ONE TWENTY TWO.
ONE TWENTY. WITH THE R. P.
EIGHT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL SB SEVEN ONE FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. FIND ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M SORRY WILL GO TO LINE A ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SH YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ROBERT M. LEE JUNIOR AND I'M A
LIFE MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND A LIFE
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. S. B. SEVEN
ONE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE TWENTY FIVE. YEAH THIS IS
JAMES WESTFALL AND FREMONT
CALIFORNIA I'M A MEMBER OF IN
OUR AGENCY RPA. AND THE
CALIFORNIA GUN OWNERS
ASSOCIATION ARE GOING TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. BLIND TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MY TWENTY FOUR.
RESEARCHERS DEMOCRAT ON THE-
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA MICHAEL
DISASSOCIATION AND ENTERING
MEMBER AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MIND ONE TWENTY FOUR.
MY NAME IS STEVE BROUGHT ON
SHERMAN OF THE MENDO LAKE
CINEMA COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION NRA LIFE MEMBER AND
I STRUGGLE WE URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE SB SEVEN SIXTEEN. THANK
YOU- WHY AND WHY NOW TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE ONE OH TWO.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CARLENE
ELLIS AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE SACRAMENTO
DEFENSE OF THE SCHOOL SHOOTERS
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
SEVEN ONE FIVE THANK YOU. I'M
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
LEFT THANK YOU. MODERATOR JEFF
SESSIONS CHECK ALONG ONE MORE
TIME FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I MIGHT. STILL BE
THERE. CERTAINLY IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE TRUST ONE OF THEM
THEY'RE ALL. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
WERE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS- THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING S. B. SEVEN ONE FIVE.
OKAY HERE IN CHINO AND WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR. I'M SORRY
CENTERS SKINNER WEB'S MOST BY
CENTER WINNER AND WE HAVE A
QUESTION JEFF. ONE COMMENT THAT
APPRECIATE- THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE- THE- OUR EXPERT OF
BRINGING FORWARD ANOTHER NEEDED
A GUN SAFETY POLICY. THANK YOU
I THINK THERE WAS SOME WATER
IRWIN. OKAY ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
SINGLE FURTHER CENTER FOURTEEN
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY HAD THE SYSTEM
BEEN IN PLACE. IN POWAY. AND
THAT TEENAGER WHO WAS DENIED
ACCESS TO THAT FIREARM. A. B.
PEOPLE STILL ALIVE. SPECTRALLY
ASPIRIN I WROTE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A- CORRECT. WE HURRIED TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. JOHN S.
B. SEVEN ONE FIVE. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE THREE
SEVEN ONE FIVE DAY PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD
BRADFORD I'D CHOI BOGUE NOW TO
ABOVE NO COM LONGER I HAVE A
LONGER AYE SKINNER. AYE SKINNER
AYE WIENER. WIENER FIVE FOUR
ONE. IT MEASURES OUT FOR THE
ONE CONGRADULATIONS SOONER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU ARE ONE-
BEFORE WE MOVED TO CENTER
NUMBER LET'S LOOK AT THE ROLE.
FOR ME OPEN THE ROLLER SHOULD
SAY. ON ANY OUTSTANDING ARMS-
METAL CONSULTANT. CONSENT
CALENDAR SB FIVE OH FOUR WIENER.
WINTERIZED FIVE ZERO IN TWO
KILLERS OUT FIVE ZERO SB SEVEN
SIXTY THREE MEN BRADFORD. HI
EDWARD I WIENER WIENER AYE FIVE
ZERO BUT MEASURE OUT SB SEVEN
SIXERS OUT FIVE ZERO. THAT
TAKES CARE OF ALL ARE
OUTSTANDING I WANT ONE MORE S.
B. FOUR NINETY THREE BRADFORD
COM LONGER. I AM A- I WINNER
WINNER I FORTY ONE. Q. FOUR
NINE THREE ZERO FOUR TO ONE GOT
A COUPLE MORE OKAY. SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO PAN. SKINNER ALL
RIGHT SKINNER I. FIVE ZERO.
FIVE ZERO AND SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN PORTANTINO DEPRESSES
AMENDED COM LOCKER HI AMONG HER
EYES FIVE ZERO. B. THREE THREE
THREE THREE SEVEN ZERO FIVE
ZERO. FIGURE NOW WE'RE CHIU
SENATOR ON FOR AND HE HAD- THIS
S. P. TWO TWELVE SIR FROM BIRTH
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
INITIALING ITS LANDMARK
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX DECISION IN
BATSON VERSUS KENTUCKY THE
SUPREME COURT SOUGHT TO
ELIMINATE RACIAL BIAS IN JURY
SELECTION BY PROVIDING PARTIES
THE RIGHT TO OBJECT TO OPPOSING
PARTIES PRINT THREE CHALLENGES.
BUT IS A JUSTICE THURGOOD
MARSHALL WROTE IN HIS PROPHETIC
CURRENT CURRENT OPINION. CIDCO
THIS TODAY WILL NOT END THE
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION THAT RAMP
DREES INJECT INTO THE JURY
SELECTION PROCESS THAT GOAL CAN
BE ACCOMPLISHED ONLY BY
ELIMINATING PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES ENTIRELY AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT. GREAT
DEAL OF EVIDENCE HAS
ACCUMULATED IN THE INTERVENING
YEARS TO PROVE THAT THE LATE
JUSTICE MARSHALL WAS CORRECT
STUDY AFTER STUDY. SHOWS THE
PRINTER JONES ARE USED TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE OF
COLOR PATTERSON NOT
WITHSTANDING AS MANY BIG
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT SOME COURTS
EFFORTS IN THOSE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT IN ITS OWN
PREQUEL BATS IN THE WHEELER
DECISION TO ELIMINATE JURY
BIAS. HAVE FAILED AMERICANS
FAITH IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
FADING FAST ATTEMPTING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM WITH HALF MEASURES
WILL NOT DO THAT'S WHY
INTRODUCED SENATE BILL TWO
TWELVE. WE TAKEN STEPS TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE IN MY
VIEW NOT GONE FAR ENOUGH- IN A
MOMENT. CHIEF JUSTICE STEPHEN
C. GONZALEZ AWASH IN SPRING
COURT WILL DISCUSS PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES. IN HIS CALL TO
ABOLISH PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
IN A TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN
CONCURRING OPINION THAT LED
WASHINGTON CHANGED ITS OWN
PRINTER RULES BOB. HE SAYS THAT
THERE ARE NO ACCURATE RELIABLE
WAY TO IDENTIFY HOW IN WHICH
PRINT THE CHALLENGES ARE BIASED
ON RACE AND WHICH ARE NOT CHIEF
JUSTICE CONSOLS EXHAUSTIVELY
RESEARCHED CONCURRENCE- IN THAT
OPINION I SAID A MOMENT AGO
INCLUDE A QUOTE FROM
PROSECUTORS SAID THAT ANY
ATTORNEY WORTH HIS. I SUPPOSE
OR HER SALT CAN MAKE UP
SOMETHING TO GET OVER A BATSON
CHALLENGE AND LITERALLY
PROSECUTORS TO MAKE IT UP
JUSTICE BRYER STEVEN BRIAR.
KNOWN AS CONCURRING OPINION IN
MILLER L. VERSUS JACKIE CASEY
SAID REINFORCED JUSTICE
MARSHALL'S CONCERNS ABOUT
PRINTING CHALLENGES THE USE OF
RACE AND GENDER BASED
STEREOTYPES THE JURY SELECTION
PROCESS SEEMS BETTER ORGANIZED
AND MORE SYSTEM. SYSTEMATIZE
THAN EVER BEFORE. HELLO A
TWENTY TWO. IS A BONTA. ISN'T
UNPOPULAR POSITION I RECOGNIZE
WITH MANY. LAWYERS WHO TRY
CASES THEY ALL BELIEVE IN JURY
SELECTION THAT THEY ARE EXPERT
IN FIGURING OUT. BASED ON THEIR
BIASES BASED ON THEIR
PREJUDICES WHO SHOULD NOT BE ON
THE JURY. HOWEVER WHEN JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DID A STUDY USING MOCK
TRIALS IT DEMONSTRATED THE
INEFFECTIVENESS OF PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES. DEFENSE LAWYERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN MOCK TRIAL BOB
WOULD HAVE DONE JUST AS WELL
HERE THEY- NOT EXERCISE THEIR
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES ARE BASED
ON A FLIP OF A COIN EXERCISE
THEIR PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES. I
WAS A AND I SUPPOSE I STILL AM
A TRIAL LAWYER AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THE BASIS IS THE
BASIS IS TO LOOK AT JURORS AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU CAN SKEW THE JURY TO YOUR
SIDE. BASED ON BIAS AND
PREJUDICE THAT IS NO PLACE IN
OUR SYSTEM. THE CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES FOR A FAIR TRIAL WITH
AN IMPARTIAL JURY AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT.
ENGLAND INVENTED PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES AND EIGHT NOW
ELIMINATED THE METABOLIC. SO
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO. MISTER
CHAIR IS I'D LIKE TO TURN TO-
ON. OUR WITNESS. LIST CHIEF
JUSTICE STEPHEN GONZALEZ WHO
WILL DISCUSS PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY POSE TO OUR SYSTEM. A
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL JUSTICE.
MISTER CHIEF JUSTICE FOR YOURS
YOUR APARTMENT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE CHANCE TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT SUBJECT.
MIKE MY COLLEAGUES JUST AS
WHERE YOU AND I ROACH INFO IN
FAVOR OF SB THIRTY SEVENTY.
WHEN IT WAS UNDER CONSIDERATION
AND I STILL BELIEVE IT WAS. A
STEP FORWARD IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. EVIDENCE MATTERS IN
FACT. BETTER RESEARCHERS YOU
HEARD SHOWS THE PRINTER
CHALLENGES ARE NOT EFFECTIVELY
USED BY ANYONE ESSENTIALLY IN
ARE THE CAUSE OF STRUCTURAL
BIAS. AGAINST POTENTIAL JURORS
OF COLOR. AND OTHER BIASES AS
WELL NOT JUST LIMITED TO THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC. AN ATTORNEY
PATERNITY DESPITE THE EVIDENCE
UNIFORMLY BELIEVE THAT THEY USE
THEM WELL EVEN IF EVERYONE ELSE
DOESN'T. ELIMINATION OF BIAS IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN MY VIEW
MUST BE DONE. SYSTEMATICALLY
AND SYSTEMICALLY. WHAT I MEAN
IS THAT BOTH SB THIRTY SEVENTY
AND S. B. TWENTY TWELVE. ARE
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS ONE FORM OR
ONE SOURCE ON THE MANIFESTATION
OF THIS BIAS SYSTEMATICALLY
THAT IS. I'M PRETTY CHALLENGES
AND HOW THEY ARE USED BY
COUNSEL IN CASES. BUT I WROTE
IN THAT OPINION YOU HEARD
REFERENCE. EIGHT YEARS AGO THAT
WE SHOULD ABOLISH PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES ALTOGETHER AND I
STILL BELIEVE. THAT THAT IS THE
BETTER COURSE. ON THE SCIENCE
AND EVIDENCE SUPPORTS IT BUT
THE ELIMINATION OF. BRENT CRUDE
CHALLENGES IS NOT A PANACEA FOR
ALL MANIFESTATIONS OF BIAS IN
OUR SYSTEM. IN WASHINGTON STATE
WE DID NOT ELIMINATE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES I RECOMMEND IT. BUT
WE ADOPTED OUR GENERAL RULE
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WAS A MODEL
FOR A BI THIRTY SEVENTY BUT I
BELIEVE IT TO BE A COMPROMISE
THAT MOVES US SUBSTANTIALLY. IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. ONE
EMPHASIZE THAT IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO SYSTEMATICALLY REDUCE BIAS.
ELIMINATION MUST ALSO BE
SYSTEMIC. DISTINGUISH
SYSTEMATIC FROM SYSTEMIC. IN
THIS WAY. SYSTEMATIC IS GETTING
A RULE THAT ADDRESSES HOW IT
MANIFESTS IN THE EXERCISE OF
PEREMPTORIES. BUT IS
INSUFFICIENT ONLY TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU ELIMINATE BIAS
IN ONE PLACE REEMERGES
SOMEWHERE ELSE IT HAS TO BE
DONE. SYSTEMICALLY AS WELL ALL
PHASES OF JURY SELECTION AND
INDEED THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED AND
REEVALUATED BUT ELIMINATION OF
BIAS THAT REASSESSMENT OF OUR
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES IN MIND-
SELECTION AT IMPROVE THE SOURCE
LIST. SELECT THE SELECTION
PROCESS NEEDS TO ELIMINATE MANY
QUESTIONS BY COUNSEL AND BY
JUDGES WHO ATTEMPT TO
REHABILITATE JURORS WITH
LEADING QUESTIONS. THAT YOU
HAVE EXPRESSED DOUBT ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO BE FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL. IT MEANS ALLOWING
COUNCIL THE TIME TO EXPLORE
ACTUAL BIAS REMAINS A PLAYING
THE RACIAL BIAS LANDS THE
HARDSHIP QUESTIONS BECAUSE
QUESTIONS AS WELL. IT MEANS
GETTING PROSPECTIVE JURORS
TALKING. NOT HAVING COUNCIL
ATTEMPTING TO ARGUE THEIR CASE.
DURING JURY SELECTION. HELP
BATTLE MEMBERS OF A POTENTIAL
JURY DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
CERTAIN. BUT THEY DO HAVE A
RIGHT NOT TO BE REMOVED FOR
IMPROPER REASONS. I BELIEVE
THAT YOU ARE THIRTY SEVEN IN
OUR STATE AND AGED THIRTY
SEVENTY WORK IF THEY WORK THEN
PERHAPS MORE YEARS WILL BE ABLE
TO KEEP THEIR PRECIOUS BUT
SCIENTIFICALLY INEFFECTIVE. THE
CHALLENGES FURTHER I SEE NO
REASON TO CREATE CIVIL CASES
DIFFERENTLY FROM CRIMINAL CASES
AND IN MY ATTEMPTS TO BE.
INTELLECTUALLY HONEST HERE.
IT'S LIKELY A POLITICAL
COMPROMISE TO DO JUST CRIMINAL
AND NOT CIVIL. SHOULD THE
LITIGATORS ARE NOT FREE FROM
THE SAME BIAS THE CRIMINAL
LITIGATORS HAVE BOTH THE
PROSECUTION AND THE DEFENSE
SUFFER FROM THIS ISSUE. I WOULD
ELIMINATE THEM ALTOGETHER AND I
WOULD REFORM THE JURY SYSTEM
PROCESS ENTIRELY TO ROOT OUT
ADDITIONAL MANIFESTATIONS OF
BIAS SO THAT IT'S NOT JUST
MOVED FROM ONE PORTION AND
ALLOWED TO. CONTINUE TO EXIST
OTHERS THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE
FOR ME TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT
PROCRIT CHALLENGES AND THE NEED
FOR US TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT
EVERY STAGE OF OUR JURY
SELECTION PROCESS BUT WELL AS
OUR PROCESS AS A WHOLE. IT IS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU CHIEF
JUSTICE NOW WILL MOVE TO.
WITNESSES AND SIDE OF FORTY TWO
OLD THREE AND SO FORTH OF FEE
TO TWELVE FIFTEEN NINE WILL
MATURE OVER FLOOR ROOM ON
TWENTY FORTY I SHOULD KNOW
WITNESSES THERE EITHER NOW WILL
GO TO OUR PHONE LINE MODERATORS
ARE THERE WITNESSES WANTING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
TWELVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISHTO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PRESTRESSED. ONE
ZERO. BUT THIS TIME THERE'S
BEEN A LONG QUEUING UP. I WILL
GIVE IT MORE ONE MORE REQUEST
IF THERE ARE WITNESSES
MODERATOR. IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THE NEW ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THEM
ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF US P. ONE SUPER
TO TWELVE I'M SORRY- WE HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES LISTED. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE AND
OPPOSITION SEEN NINE NOW WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE
NO WITNESSES THERE EITHER.
MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES WITH THIS IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO TWELVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE TRUST ONE ANOTHER AND
THEY'RE ALL. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO I BELIEVE THEIR
CLIENT PRIMARY THERE IS ANOTHER
OPTION. THERE ARE TOO LATE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YES
THIS IS BURNING WOOD GRANTED
ONLY TO COUNTY I BELIEVE MOST
DEMOCRATS CIRCUM PLEASE ALSO
NOTE. YES THANK YOU SHARE
BRADFORD AND MEMBERS I'M ALSO
DESIGNATED AS THE LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION I AM WITH THEM
ALL A FACULTY MEMBER UC
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW WHERE I
DIRECT THE DEATH PENALTY
CLINIC. I HAVE SPENT MANY OF MY
FORTY PLUS YEARS AS A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE LAWYER OPPOSING
DISCRIMINATORY JURY SELECTION
PRACTICES. A HIGH POINT IN
THOSE AFTER LAST. BUT SEVERAL
OF MY STUDENTS AND I PUBLISHED
WHITEWASHING THE JURY BOX WHICH
WE SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVENTY. GRAND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DR SHIRLEY WEBER LANDMARK CIVIL
RIGHTS. LEGISLATION EVIDENCE
BASED FOUNDATION FOR AB THIRTY
SEVENTY WHAT'S SALAS. I REPORT
TO THE WASHINGTON SUPREME COURT
RECOMMENDED G. R. THIRTY SEVEN
ON WHICH WE MODELED AB THIRTY
SEVENTY. OUR REPORT EXHAUSTIVE
INVESTIGATION INTO PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES IN CALIFORNIA
CRIMINAL TRIAL. DEMONSTRATED
HOW PROSECUTORS USED THEIR
STRIKE. DISPROPORTIONATELY
REMOVE BLACK JURORS AND HOW
ABOUT THE WHEELER PROCEDURE IN
PLACE FOR DECADES HAD FAILED TO
ELIMINATE DISCRIMINATION. THE
WASHINGTON REPORT AND HOURS AS
JUSTICE GONZALEZ MENTIONED
REJECTED ENDING PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES. THROUGHOUT THE
SESSION LAST YEAR WE WORKED TO
REACH AGREEMENTS WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CRIMINALIZED
BY THREE COMMITTEE. AB THIRTY
SEVENTY LANGUAGE DEEPLY
TROUBLING TO ME THAT SENATOR-
BURKE WOULD INVOKE JUSTICE
THURGOOD MARSHALL IN HIS EFFORT
TO REPEAL THE. HISTORIC
LEGISLATION. AND JUSTICE MARCH
LEVEL COURT. AFTER SUPREME
PROCEDURE. MORE REDUCE
PROSECUTORS DISCRIMINATORY
RIGHT. LEARN HOW PROSECUTORS
WOULD DEBATE PROCEDURE AND
JUDGE WOULD BE UNABLE ENFORCE
IT AB THIRTY SEVENTY ADDRESSES
EACH CRITIQUE WITH DUE RESPECT
TO JUSTICE GONZALEZ IS ELOQUENT
REMARKS THIS MORNING AND I
CONCUR WITH MANY OF THEM IN SO
FAR AS- THE NEED FOR SYSTEMATIC
AND SYSTEMIC REFORM A JURY
SELECTION. SB TWO TWELVE
PREMISE IS THAT BECAUSE
CHALLENGES ALONE WILL PROTECT
AGAINST RACE DISCRIMINATION IN
JURY SELECTION EVIDENCE IS TO
THE CONTRARY BECAUSE CHALLENGES
ARE AS INTERTWINED WITH
DISCRIMINATION AND PRINT YOUR
STRIKE PROSECUTORS ALSO EMPLOY
THEM TO DISCRIMINATORY LEAGUE
RECRUIT BLACK JURORS. ENDING
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES WITH OUT
AT THIRTY SEVENTY DIED IN
WRECKING LEGAL GUARDRAILS
AGAINST THE USE OF RECENT
HISTORICALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
DISCRIMINATION WELL INCREASED
JUDICIAL TOLERANT OF EXPLICIT
IMPLICIT AND INSTITUTIONALIZED
IN BECAUSE CHALLENGE BECAUSE
CHALLENGES. I URGE YOU TO
REJECT SB TWO TWELVE AND TAKE
THE WHOLE HISTORIC STEP OF
IMPLEMENTING AB. THIRTY SEVENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
LOOK FOR BROWN MORE. RENDON I'M
SORRY GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
CRAP ME CAN YOU HEAR ME. AND
I'LL CONTINUE GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BRANDON WHICH I'M THE
PUBLIC FROM ABOUT A COUNTY I AM
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN TO
BE PART OF THE PRINTER ABOUT ME
TO COUNTY I'M CURRENTLY THE
ONLY BLACK CHIEF PUBLIC
DEFENDER ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'LL TELL YOU THAT
I'M SADDENED AND THE THIRD THAT
WOULD BE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY.
I AM CONCERNED BECAUSE OVER THE
COURSE OF MY CAREER HI CAN
COUNTLESS YOUNG BLACK MEN GO TO
TRIAL. WHAT CHARGES MAY NOT A
SINGLE BLACK PERSON ON THEIR
JURY. OVER THE YEARS THIS BODY
TAKEN ARE PART OF THE STEPS TO
CREATE RACIAL DIVERSITY OR
JURIES BUDGET PACKAGE SB THREE
TEN BY SKINNER. SB FIVE MANY
TRUE BY SENATOR WIENER WHICH
EXPAND THE LIST OF JURY HELD
WAS YOURS. OF COURSE AB THIRTY
SEVENTY AUTHORED BY DR SHIRLEY
WEBER THE FIRST BLACK SECRETARY
OF STATE IN CALIFORNIA. AB
THIRTY SEVEN WITH BOLD RESTORED
LANDMARK CIVIL RIGHTS
LEGISLATION. AND A TREMENDOUS
STEP TOWARD ELIMINATING RACIAL
BIAS IN JURY SELECTION. BEFORE
LEGISLATION YOU HAVE THE CHANCE
TO TAKE AFFECT. SB TWO TWELVE.
INTRODUCED TO COMPLETELY WIPED
FROM THE BOOKS TO REMOVE IT
FROM THE COKE. AS THE PRESS
THREE I'VE SEEN PROPERTIES
REMOVE JURORS OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY BLACK JURORS JURORS
FOR REASONS SUCH AS THE JUROR
HAD A NEGATIVE INTERACTION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. YOUR BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN GET RESERVE
PROFILING OR BECAUSE THAT YOUR
NEW PEOPLE THAT WERE ARRESTED.
OR FOUND THAT THEY WERE
ARRESTED. WE HAVE BEEN AMONG.
FROM JURIES FOR THE SENATE WITH
BLACK IN AMERICA. AB THIRTY
SEVENTY MAKES DOES WILLIAMS
PRESUMPTIVELY INVALID. IT
REMOVES MUCH OF THE RACISM AND
BIAS EXISTED AND QUICKLY
CHALLENGES. AND INSTEAD OF
STAYING WE CAN ABIDE BY THOSE
RULES WHO CAN AFFORD BEING
BIASED WE CAN AVOID BASED ON
YOUR SELECTION THEY WOULD
RATHER ELIMINATE QUICKLY
CHALLENGES ALL TO GET. AND BY
DOING SO. THEY WILL BE MOVED TO
POWER OF THE RESPECTIVE FROM
PROSECUTORS. FROM DIFFERENT
JOURNEYS FROM THOSE ACCUSED OF
CRIMES EMPLACEMENT HIGHLY IN
THE HANDS OF JUDGES. YOUR IS A
GLORIFIED OF ALL WHITE MEN. BUT
IT SB TWO TALL PATTON'S THIS IS
ABOUT WHO WILL BE APPROPRIATE
JEWELERS GRAMMAR CASE WILL BE
TURNED BY JUDGE. OTHER WORDS
FOR GROUP ARE PREDOMINATELY
WHITE MET. THIS LAW THE STEP
BACK WHICH- BLACK PEOPLE UNABLE
TO JUSTICE IN AMERICA. WE DO
NOT WISH YOU JUST WERE RESTED
PROSECUTED. THANK CAGED. AND WE
DO NOT WE ARE MURDERED BY
POLICE. WE WILL NEVER RECEIVE
JUSTICE I'M NOT ALLOWED TO
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE LOOK IF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN. THE PATCHWORK SYSTEM
GRAYSON MARK YEAH. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE NOBLE
SB TWO TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I APOLOGIZE FOR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NOW WILL GO BACK TO THE
MODERATE OUR PHONE LINE AND SEE
IF THERE ARE WITNESSES IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION OF US THREE TO
TWELVE. THANK YOU AND AGAIN IF
YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE NOW AND THEN THERE
OUGHT THIS TIME ONE OF THEM
ZERO. LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FORTY I'M SORRY LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MIND ONE THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON GLENN BACKUS PADILLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO A NURSE AND LINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL WE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WITH STRONG
OPPOSITION. LINE ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES IT
NOT SURE NANDO'S ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. NINE ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON GREG REPUBLICAN ISSUE
JUSTICE RESPECTFULLY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAITLYN GREEN
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
RESPECTFULLY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
MODERATOR ARE JUST SAID SHE
CHECKED ALONG ONE MORE TIME FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CERTAINLY IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM THEY'RE ALL.
AND THERE IS NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME- KIDDING NO MORE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON
BY THE COMMITTEE AS IT RELATES
TO A SPEECH. TO TWELVE. SENATOR
SKINNER. M. THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT- AS IS EVIDENCED BY THE
TESTIMONY FROM OUR CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT JUDGES IT- VERY
STRONGLY HELD OPINIONS. AND
ALSO EVIDENCED BY THE OTHER
TESTIMONY WE HEARD WE- DID HAVE
DEBATED BILLS BY- SENATOR
JACKSON BY- BYE THESE ARE
PREVIOUS BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY WEBER AND OTHERS ON
THIS QUESTION- AND THEY WERE
PILOT PROGRAMS AND SUCH. BUT WE
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW THE
BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
WHICH AS I UNDERSTAND IT THIS
BILL WOULD IN EFFECT ON
DUKEREPORT PORTIONS OF IT. AND
I FEEL THAT. IT WAS NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO DO SO AT
THIS TIME. AND THAT WHILE IT IS
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE TO
MONITOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT AND TO. STE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER IT HAS THE IT WHETHER
IT EASIER PROCEEDS AS THE
AUTHOR INTENDED WITH THAT
MOTIVATION OR WHETHER IT
CREATES THE TYPE OF CONSEQUENCE
THAT WOULD APPEAR THE- ISSUE
YOU IN THE PROPONENTS OF YOUR
BILL FEEL IT MAY- BUT I THINK
AT THIS POINT GIVEN THAT IT WAS
JUST ENACTED IS NOT APPROPRIATE
TO UNDO IT. AND IF YOU WANT TO
COME INTO A YOU MAY. SERVICE
CHAIR. WOULD LIKE TO COME IN
OUR MY CLOTHES FONG HOW DO YOU
PLEASE OF WELL. S. ANNOUNCES TO
SENATOR SKINNER IS COMMON I
DON'T DO THIS IS UNDOING THIRTY
SEVENTY WHAT I WHAT I DO THIS
IS TAKING IT A STEP FURTHER- SO
LONG HELD BELIEF THAT. WE HAVE
A SYSTEM A PROCESS THAT IS
FLAWED IS A PROCESS THAT IS
BASED ON SIMPLY RAW PREJUDICE
THAT'S WHAT IT'S BASED UPON.
EACH SIDE EACH SIDE IS TRYING
TO SKEW THE JURY TO AN OUTCOME
THAT THEY BELIEVE IT IS IN
THEIR FAVOR I WAS PLACES CIVIL
CASES AS WELL NOT JUST CRIMINAL
CASE USUAL NOTE THERE WERE NO
DJS THEY WERE THAT. WAS A DID
NOT TESTIFY DEREK BECAUSE THEY
ALSO BOTH SIDES ONE SKEW THE
JERK. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENS NOW. WHAT DOES IT I DO
BELIEVE AS IS CHIEF JUSTICE
GONZALEZ ILLUSTRATED THE NEED
TO BE FURTHER REFORM IN TERMS
OF ENLARGING THE VENEER. VERY
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT. CHALLENGES FOR CAUSE
A GRANTED LIBERALLY. VERY
IMPORTANT MAKING SURE THAT IF A
CHILD FOR CAUSES NOT GRANTED
AND THERE IS A REASON THAT YOU
CAN OBJECT AND YOU CAN BRING
THAT FORWARD. GOOD IDEA BUT
SIMPLY HAVING A SYSTEM WERE
TINKERING WITH. WE'RE TINKERING
WITH PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
WHICH ARE FUNDAMENTALLY BASED
ON BIAS AND PREJUDICE. I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE A STEP FURTHER.
THE TWO CLOSEST CONCERTS IN A
WINNER. THANK YOU I'M TRYING TO
DEVELOP. THIS IS MADE BY THE
AUTHOR. SIR AT THE END OF A
SESSION SORRY FOR MY VOICE
AGAIN DECISION LAST YEAR THE
AUTHOR AND I HAD- SEVERAL
LENGTHY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR- OUR
DIFFERING VIEWS ON AB- THIRTY
SEVENTY ONE UP. WHEN I WAS.
WHEN THAT WAS ON THE FLOOR- AND
I OF COURSE I WAS THE BY WAS
THE FLOOR MANAGER OF AB THIRTY
SEVEN DAY I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL- AND I'M GLAD WE WERE ABLE
TO PASS IT. ON I AS I EXPRESS
THE AUTO TIME I OF- MY I'M NOT
LIKE THE BIGGEST CHAMPION OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES IS A
FORMER CIVIL TRIAL. ATTORNEY
AND I'VE SEEN THE PROS AND THE
CONS AND THERE ARE PROS AND
CONS TO PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT'S IT THAT THERE ARE. ISSUES
WITH THE SYSTEM AND I'M NOT
HERE TO SORT OF- CLASS GLANCE
OVER THAT BUT WITH THAT SAID I
ALSO DO BELIEVE THAT IT BE
THIRTY SEVENTY- WAS WAS A
LANDMARK LAW. I THINK IT'S A
GOOD LAW DO- IN MY VIEW I'D
JUST LIKE TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE IMPLEMENTED-
AND THEN ON THIS BROADER ISSUE
PEREMPTORIES WE CAN ALL WE CAN
REVISIT IT YOU KNOW IF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOR WHATEVER
REASON ISN'T WORKING I THINK IT
LIKELY WILL WORK- AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM WASHINGTON STATE BY-
I DO WANNA GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY
SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY I DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR. CONTINUING TO RAISE
THIS ISSUE- BUT I WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT. NO COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SENATOR ULTRABOOK.
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE HAVE-
THE TURNING RIGHT HERE
PRESENTING THE BILL AND WE HAVE
AN ATTORNEY HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE AND IT'S INTERESTING
HOW- WE COME UP WITH DIFFERING
VIEWS AND ANGLES IN IN IN
POLICY- HAVING SAID THAT I DO
APPRECIATE. THE EFFORT OF OR
THE STATEMENT THAT YOU MADE
THAT YOU ARE NOT TRYING TO-
BASICALLY NULLIFIER OR OUT DO
THE AB THIRTY SEVENTY THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO IMPROVE THAT-
AND JUST MOVE IT A STEP
FURTHER. FASHION AND I IT WAS
INTERESTING ALSO TO NOTE THE
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF CHIEF
JUSTICE STEPHEN GONZALEZ- AND
THEN. ALSO. PROFESSORS AT
SIMONE SIMONE ON AND GET SOME
MORE AND- AND THE DEFENDER-
WOODS- ON THIS ISSUE- OBVIOUSLY
IS VERY VERY COMPLICATED AND
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN THIS IN
THIS BILL AND- WITH THAT INTENT
OF TRYING TO IMPROVE- A CURRENT
SYSTEM NOT OUT DOING AB THIRTY
SEVENTY I WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO MOVE. THIS THIS THIS
BILL FORWARD- IN ORDER FOR IT
TO HOPEFULLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE ITS
WORK- AND I THINK ULTIMATELY I
THINK EVERYBODY HAS- THE INTENT
OF IMPROVING A SYSTEM THAT IS
FLAWED- AND WITH THAT I RESPECT
YOUR INTENT- AS THE AUTHOR-
ADDITION COMMENTER. QUESTIONS
UPON THIS ROCK. I TWO ONE
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR I BELIEVE YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE GENUINE. BUT
STATED BY MY OTHER COLLEAGUES I
THINK THIS MEASURE IS PREMATURE
OR UNDERSTANDING THAT- AB
THIRTY SEVENTY DOES NOT EVEN GO
INTO EFFECT TILL JANUARY OF
NEXT YEAR AND I THINK IT SHOULD
HAVE IT STAND THE SUN TO PROVE.
THAT IT WORKS OR IT CAN IMPROVE
UPON A SYSTEM IN A PROCESSOR WE
ALL AGREE IS FLAWED IT'S ALL WE
ALL AGREE IS BIAS. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IT'S MONUMENTAL
LEGISLATION THAT WE VOTED FOR
LAST YEAR AND IT SHOULD HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES- PROVE ITSELF
WORTHY. BEFORE CHANGING IT AS A
WHOLE SO THERE ANALYZE MY
CONCERN HERE- NOT WITH THE.
INTENT OF THE AUTHOR AND HIS.
GENUINE COMMITMENT TRY TO OUR
STARTS- WE WOULD ALL AGREE AS A
STATED IS FLAWED BUT- IT'S ONE
THAT I THINK IT'S TIME IS
HASN'T COME YET. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS TO I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE BUT- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
AND IF YOU'D LIKE YOU CAN CLOSE
AT THIS POINT. THANK YOU MISTER
I'LL BE BRIEF- I THINK THIS IS
A CONTINUING CONVERSATION I
THINK THERE'S A CONVERSATION
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FOR SOMETIME
TO COME. BECAUSE I THINK ALL OF
US WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHETHER IT'S A CIVIL TRIAL OR
CRIMINAL TRIAL THAT THERE IS
FAIR AND EQUITABLE JUSTICE AND
THOSE WHO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
ARE A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL JURY
YOU'VE HEARD WHAT THEY HAD TO
SAY ABOUT HOW PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES IMPACT A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL JURY AND I WORRY I
WORRY I'VE HEARD ONE SIDE OF
THE ARGUMENT YOU KNOW WE HAD A
TRAVESTY. IN SOUTHERN
<c.green>ALIFORNIA MANY YEARS AGO BUT</c>
WITHIN OUR MEMORY AND I WAS THE
RODNEY KING TRIAL THAT WAS A
CLEAR EXAMPLE OF HOW
PEREMPTORIES CAN BE USED FOR IN
MY VIEW ON THE FERRY IS
PURPOSE. AND SO I'LL CONTINUE
THIS AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS- WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
THIS DIALOGUE I THINK WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
FOR SOME TIME AND WITH THAT I.
WOULD ASK FOR AND I WILL. GREET
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE THE MOST ON
S. B. TWO TWELVE- A TO DO
PASSAGE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MA'AM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SB TWO TWELVE DO PATH
TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD NO
BUT FOR NOW IT CHOI BOGUE I
TROUBLE GUY COM WONDER NO
LONGER NO SKINNER. SKINNER NOT
VOTING WINNER WINNER NO BOATS
ONE TWO THREE. MEASURES ONE
THREE IT FAILS ON THIS CHAIR I
THINK YOU HAVE TO BE HEARD
THANK YOU SENATOR BRIDGET.
MEMBERS OF- THERE'S NO OTHER
THING ANOTHER ITEMS ON OUR
AGENDA I BELIEVE THIS CONCLUDES
OUR- I WORK FOR THE DAY I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ARE RIDING TO. THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR CUTS
COMMENTS AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE STANDS
ADJOURNED.